all right um this is the taproot therapy podcast um i'm joel blackstock and i'm here with a man truly needs no introduction. Philosopher King, you know, rock star, published author, world traveler, collector of rare artifacts, esoteric magic specialist. Samuel Blanchett,
好的，嗯，这是Taproot Therapy播客，我是Joel Blackstock，今天我请到了一位真正不需要介绍的人。哲学家国王，你知道的，摇滚明星，出版作家，世界旅行家，稀有文物收藏家，深奥魔法专家。Samuel Blanchett，
am I saying that right, is another social worker who reached out to me. And, you know, we're both kind of in a similar world and a ton of the stuff that I've done, I think it's just because our website is a little bit more visible. As people see ideas and they're kind of looking for people in their world. how academic psychology is going in a different direction than clinical practice um because the market is wanting things that um are not happening in the hospitals by and large which is not a great place for the profession to be in and um anyway i have a lot of these conversations like on the phone with people that want to connect and like they're fun and they're interesting and i i learn a bunch of stuff and so decided i'm just going to start doing that on the podcast one because i'm
我名字念对了吗？他是另一位联系我的社会工作者。你知道，我们都在一个相似的领域，我做过很多事情，我想这只是因为我们的网站稍微显眼一点。当人们看到这些想法时，他们会在自己的圈子里寻找志同道合的人。学术心理学正朝着与临床实践不同的方向发展，嗯，因为市场需求的东西，嗯，在医院里大体上并没有发生，这对这个行业来说不是一个好的处境，而且，嗯，总之，我经常和那些想要交流的人通电话，这些对话很有趣，很有意思，我学到了很多东西，所以我决定开始在播客上做这件事，首先是因为我
out of time all i do is therapy podcast and play with my kids and sleep and so yeah Sam was a really interesting nice guy who reached out and wanted to connect and I'm sure we'll have a fascinating conversation so thank you so much for being here can you introduce your your actual biography yeah so aside from my Arcanium of, you know, esoteric skills and my treasure-seeking and so forth. I should have come up with more like antiquated titles like alienist, you know, things like that. Haberdasher, yeah, farrier. All of those things in the progression of learning how to be a human, right? Yeah. So yes, I'm a random human being that reached out to you because I saw that you had found a really kind of lovely way of integrating some of the modern neurological approaches with
没时间了，我所做的就是治疗、播客、陪孩子玩和睡觉，所以是的，Sam是一个非常有趣、友善的人，他主动联系我想要交流，我相信我们会进行一场精彩的对话，所以非常感谢你能来，你能介绍一下你真实的履历吗？好的，除了我那些深奥的技能、寻宝之类的东西。我本该想出更多像“精神病学家”这样古老的头衔，你知道，诸如此类的。男装店老板，是的，钉蹄匠。所有这些都是学习如何成为人类过程中的一部分，对吧？是的。所以，是的，我是一个偶然联系到你的普通人，因为我看到你找到了一种非常棒的方法，将一些现代神经学方法与
some of the cool, more philosophical approaches. I don't think there's really a distinction there, but just to make discrimination between as if we could do that to ourselves we're not romantic distinction only really yes and so I am a master's level clinician with license associate clinician so I'm working towards my ultimate end goal and whatever that is. What are your stages here? Because here the C is the terminal license. Interesting. Yeah. So I'm in Arizona.
一些很酷的、更哲学的方法结合起来。我不认为这两者之间真的有什么区别，但仅仅是为了做出区分，就好像我们能对自己做这件事一样，我们并不是只有浪漫的区分，是的，所以我是一名硕士级别的临床医生，拥有执照助理临床医生资格，所以我正在朝着我的最终目标努力，无论那是什么。你这里的阶段是什么？因为在这里，C是最终执照。有趣。是的，我在亚利桑那州。
So that, and it is different across all the states. And my degree is actually in counseling. So I'm not coming from the social working realm. When you said LCS, because here it's ALC, LPC, and then social is counselor. And then social worker is LG SW which they just changed to LMS W and then it turns into L I CSW which used to be LC SW in our board and it's infinite wisdom there's some others around absolutely I really appreciate some of the states though that are working on doing kind of
所以，这在各个州都是不同的。我的学位实际上是咨询。所以我不是来自社会工作领域。当你提到LCS时，因为这里是ALC、LPC，然后社会工作是咨询师。然后社会工作者是LGSW，他们刚刚改成了LMSW，然后变成了LICSW，这在我们的委员会中曾经是LCSW，那里有无限的智慧，还有其他一些，绝对是这样，我真的很欣赏一些正在努力做某种
interstate compacts as far as that goes I think that's kind of a really cool counselors are so much better at it than the social workers um and it's like and i think there's there's pros and cons to both ones but overall it seems like the social workers have like a little bit less self-esteem or something like i don't know what it is um and the boards seem like we're like during the pandemic of the counseling boards are like getting together and the clinical psychology boards are making everything apas like making everything like so much easier for the licensed to practice across straight lines and meet this need in a mental health crisis and like our board is making it harder and being like actually there's these
州际契约的州，就这一点而言，我认为这真的很酷，咨询师在这方面比社会工作者做得好得多，嗯，而且就像，我认为两者都有利有弊，但总的来说，社会工作者似乎自尊心稍微低一点，或者类似的东西，我不知道是什么，嗯，而且委员会看起来就像我们在疫情期间，咨询委员会就像聚在一起，临床心理学委员会正在让一切变得像APA一样，让一切变得更容易跨州执业，以满足心理健康危机的需求，而我们的委员会却在增加难度，并说实际上有这些
hoops because we have to make extra sure um which i mean there's maybe ways to do it but it's just like they keep raising the number of ethics hours because they're like well people keep sleeping with their patients so maybe that they're doing that because they haven't heard it for eight hours instead of four and it's like no like that i i don't think no one i don't think no one told them not to do it is the problem pretty much like introduction to you want to be a mental health professional they're gonna be so bored that we are gonna kill the libido of the entire profession i mean it's like you you you need to kind of catch that and the uh education level and the support level and um the licensure level which for some
障碍，因为我们必须格外确定，嗯，我的意思是，也许有办法做到这一点，但就像他们不断增加道德学时数，因为他们觉得，好吧，人们一直在和病人发生性关系，所以也许他们这样做是因为他们没有听够八小时，而不是四小时，这就像，不，我不认为没有人告诉他们不要这样做才是问题所在，基本上就像向你介绍你想成为一名心理健康专业人士，他们会感到非常无聊，以至于我们会扼杀整个行业的性欲，我的意思是，这就像你需要捕捉到这一点，以及教育水平和支持水平，以及执照水平，这对于某些
reason it's only we'll just tack on these CEs and, and that'll fix these problems retroactively, which is supposed to be the system's profession. Social workers are supposed to understand the system as it actually works, not as we wish it did. You know, the stereotype is the LPC is kind of in a vacuum being like symptomology, which is always true. And the social worker is more like person and environment, food, racism, culture, you know, but for some reason,
原因来说，我们只会加上这些CE（继续教育），然后，这就能追溯性地解决这些问题，这应该是系统的专业。社会工作者应该理解系统是如何实际运作的，而不是我们希望它如何运作。你知道，刻板印象是LPC有点在真空中，就像症状学，这总是正确的。而社会工作者更像是人与环境、食物、种族主义、文化，你知道，但出于某种原因，
those are not the ones that uh that make the loss about someone yeah and i think that's you know that's an interesting point that you make about coming into this field right and i think to some degree well it seems that human beings have an interest in how their minds psyches souls work right how this thing functions because we all experience suffering and so we try to create methods of managing whatever that is, right? And I think that that's such an interesting point about this, like creating an education of so many hours to try and inform you of information. And there's such a huge difference between the experience of sitting with somebody in an intensely emotional space and the theoretical constructs around sitting with somebody
那些并不是关于某人的损失，是的，我认为这是一个有趣的观点，关于进入这个领域，对吧？我认为在某种程度上，人类对他们的思想、心灵、灵魂如何运作感兴趣，对吧？这个东西是如何运作的，因为我们都经历过痛苦，所以我们试图创造管理这一切的方法，对吧？我认为关于这一点，比如创造一个这么多小时的教育来试图告知你信息，这是一个非常有趣的观点。而在一个强烈的情感空间里与某人坐在一起的体验，与围绕与某人坐在一起的理论结构之间，有着巨大的差异
in emotional space mm-hmm and everybody who doesn't do that seems to want to tell you how to you know the the psychiatrist that has never been in therapy and doesn't practice therapy and the right and the head of the insurance board and the state legislature have all these opinions about things they don't do like teach children or do counseling yes all of those pieces and i and i think i mean you used to really i mean explicit example right this idea of like oh they keep on like engaging in relationships with these uh you know people that it's outside of the framework and the boundaries of the like the holding container right and at the same time if you don't know how to work with the energy of human connection, right? Like the intensity of that on the levels that are necessary to some degree to like...
在情感空间里，嗯，每个人如果不这样做，似乎都想告诉你该怎么做，你知道，从未接受过治疗且不进行治疗的精神科医生，以及保险委员会和州立法机构的负责人，他们对他们不从事的事情都有各种意见，比如教孩子或做咨询，是的，所有这些部分，而且我，我的意思是，你曾经真的，我的意思是明确的例子，对吧？这种想法，比如，哦，他们不断地与这些，你知道，框架和边界之外的人建立关系，比如保持容器，对吧？与此同时，如果你不知道如何处理人类连接的能量，对吧？比如在某种程度上必要的强度，比如……
And for multiple types of people, you kind of got to be a chameleon. You need to be what they need, not what you want. Absolutely. And to stay with that is is interesting i think that's a huge part of what our field does we we create mental constructs in order to feel safe when we're journeying into the unknown and i think um you know brain spotting i think that they he the author makes a really interesting point about like this quadrillion connections in the human brain and i think that that's lovely to be aware of
对于多种类型的人，你必须成为变色龙。你需要成为他们需要的，而不是你想要的。绝对是。并且保持这一点是很有趣的，我认为这是我们领域所做工作的很大一部分，我们创造心理结构是为了在进入未知领域时感到安全，我认为，嗯，你知道，脑点（Brainspotting），我认为作者提出了一个非常有趣的观点，关于人类大脑中数千万亿的连接，我认为意识到这一点很好
because I think one thing I've noticed as a struggle is they boards and other you know trends try to dictate what is the right way of doing therapy and oh boy I've had so many internal conflicts or like you can do the right thing for the wrong reasons or the wrong thing for the right reasons. You know, it's like, like there's some people who use exercises and avoidance, you know? So if they're processing trauma with brain spotting, stop exercising. It's not that that's a bad thing to do, you know, but it's like, so a lot of times I think when you put more control at the top level, you're just making providers sort of have a different
因为我认为我注意到的一件事是一个挣扎，委员会和其他，你知道，趋势试图规定什么是做治疗的正确方式，天哪，我有很多内部冲突，或者就像你可以因为错误的原因做正确的事，或者因为正确的原因做错误的事。你知道，就像，有些人使用练习和回避，你知道吗？所以如果他们正在用脑点处理创伤，停止锻炼。并不是说这是一件坏事，你知道，但就像，所以很多时候我认为当你把更多的控制权放在最高层时，你只是让提供者以一种不同的方式
aesthetic about doing what they're doing anyway you know it doesn't actually change practice that much if anything it makes it worse yeah yeah this idea of having to change the language that you express the thing that you're going to be doing naturally anyway well and like the whole profession i mean i think that's like why mental health is such an a weird spot is it's like, because you see it if you're a social worker, and you're working with like grants and things. Yes. But there's all these assumptions baked in to the way the rules are written, that there's services that exist and connections and things that
审美来做他们正在做的事情，你知道，它实际上并没有改变多少实践，如果有的话，它会让情况变得更糟，是的，是的，这种必须改变你表达你无论如何都会自然做的事情的语言的想法，嗯，而且就像整个行业，我的意思是，我认为这就是为什么心理健康处于一个奇怪的位置，因为如果你是一名社会工作者，并且你正在处理拨款之类的事情，你就会看到它。是的。但是规则的编写方式中存在着所有这些假设，即存在服务、连接和事物，这些
have not been around for 30 years. So like half of it is ticking boxes that are fake just because it used to work this certain way and and like it's not quite a catch-22 but we need a word for that i mean and one of the things is it's like psychiatrists know how to do therapy it's just this assumption because i know how to read research about cbt and it's like no we we used to think that because it used to be true because they used to do therapy and they used to be in therapy and now the vast majority of them are not but for some reason they're the one that calls me you know from an insurance panel that i'm no longer in that says well you should be able to treat dissociative
已经有30年没有出现了。所以一半是勾选虚假的框框，仅仅是因为它过去是这样运作的，而且这不完全是“第22条军规”，但我们需要一个词来形容它，我的意思是，其中一件事是，精神科医生知道如何做治疗，这只是一个假设，因为我知道如何阅读关于CBT的研究，而这就像，不，我们过去认为那样，因为过去确实如此，因为他们过去做治疗，他们过去接受治疗，而现在绝大多数人不再这样做了，但出于某种原因，他们是那个打电话给我的人，你知道，来自一个我不再加入的保险小组，说，好吧，你应该能够在三次疗程内用CBT或药物治疗解离性
identity disorder in three sessions with cbt or drugs are mandated and no more therapy will be paid for and also brain spotting isn't evidence-based and neither is emdr and neither is like you know some other long list of stuff she wanted me to it was like hey uh have you ever done this like i mean i asked it'd be that they like they i i left the panel and then they were like well fine and now they call me every year and ask me to go back in i never will but they're like um you know like i don't know was it your dream to be the member of a 15 person, you know, fake referral insurance thing that's local to this zip code? Like, what are you doing? Why are you telling me how to do therapy? You've never done it. And I don't know. cases it actually like bears really pleasant fruit right like some of the really cool um neurological studies and some of the like neuropsych stuff um what i really love about it in all honesty is it gives credence to a lot of historical and traditional methods of working with people and
身份障碍，并且不再支付治疗费用，而且脑点不是基于证据的，EMDR也不是，还有其他一些长长的清单，她想让我……这就像，嘿，你做过这个吗？就像，我的意思是，我问过，他们，我离开了小组，然后他们说，好吧，没问题，现在他们每年都打电话给我，让我回去，我永远不会，但他们就像，嗯，你知道，我不知道，成为一个15人的、你知道，虚假的转介保险机构的成员是你的梦想吗？那是本地邮政编码的？你到底在做什么？你为什么要告诉我怎么做治疗？你从来没做过。我不知道。案例实际上确实结出了非常令人愉快的果实，对吧？比如一些非常酷的神经学研究和一些神经心理学的东西，嗯，老实说，我真正喜欢它的是，它为许多历史和传统的与人工作的方法提供了可信度，并且
now we can just label it with scientific terms and say it's good an example that i really like so memory reconsolidation, I think is so lovely. And that's really been encouraging to me, this idea that there is a way that the brain changes things fundamentally, permanently. Love that. It's very encouraging to me. And in my process of doing therapy,
现在我们可以用科学术语来标记它，并说它是好的，我非常喜欢的一个例子，记忆重构（Memory Reconsolidation），我认为这太可爱了。这对我来说真的很鼓舞人心，这种大脑从根本上、永久地改变事物的想法。喜欢这个。这对我来说非常鼓舞人心。在我的治疗过程中，
I deeply fell in love with Gestalt therapy at the very beginning of things. I have the book, Ego, Hunger and Aggression. And and i'm like oh my goodness i really love the the depth of this thing rich pearls it was a it was he was an interesting guy yeah he was i think a lot of you know we have videos and we use that to interpret a certain total system and philosophical approach which is it is what it is and that's what people do but um his wife laura pearls contributed so much um goodman all these different thinkers contributed to this really really lovely existential approach to therapy uh and yeah i think its downfall was kind of two things too it's like one he was kind of a little bit more of a showman he was probably kind of like
我在事情刚开始时就深深地爱上了格式塔疗法（Gestalt therapy）。我有那本书，《自我、饥饿与攻击》。而且我当时想，哦，天哪，我真的很喜欢这个东西的深度，Rich Pearls，他是一个有趣的人，是的，我想很多，你知道，我们有视频，我们用它来解释一个特定的整体系统和哲学方法，它就是它，这就是人们所做的，但是，嗯，他的妻子Laura Perls贡献了这么多，Goodman，所有这些不同的思想家都为这种非常、非常可爱的存在主义治疗方法做出了贡献，嗯，是的，我认为它的衰落大概是两件事，就像第一，他有点像个表演者，他可能有点像
me like you want it was like you're not i want to show you how well this thing works by demonstrating it and so people thought it was too reductive no not reductive they thought it was like too much of like a um i don't know just some kind of a tri technique or something instead of he was showing them part of a system and then also like east and west coast gestalt kind of got in a fight i mean it's like the middle of california people were like this should be therapy and the other people are like it should be religion which i i guess your therapy modality is successful if it accidentally forms like a religion slash cult you know i don't know like a philosophical life uh approach yeah i think uh that's i you're absolutely right though about that thing and i think the the challenge that
我，就像你想要，就像我想通过演示来向你展示这个东西有多有效，所以人们认为它太简化了，不，不是简化，他们认为它太像某种技巧之类的东西，而不是他在向他们展示一个系统的一部分，然后还有东海岸和西海岸的格式塔有点打架，我的意思是，加州中部的人说这应该是治疗，而其他人说这应该是宗教，我想如果你的治疗模式不小心形成了像宗教/邪教一样的东西，它是成功的，你知道，我不知道，就像一种哲学生活方式，是的，我认为，你是绝对正确的，关于那件事，我认为挑战在于
happens the unfortunate thing is like when certain people take things to their extreme especially when part of the whole thing is trying to keep ideas alive to some degree like let me like you like you said let me show you something cool right and I think what that winds up doing though is like especially in the case of like gestalt therapy like here's this like beautiful um theoretical idea right field theory dialogical approach i am thou phenomenology relationship the in-between bracketing all these brilliant really lovely existential concepts kind of like flowing into this approach um and then we wind up with like
发生的不幸的事情是，当某些人把事情推向极端时，特别是当整个事情的一部分是试图在某种程度上保持想法的活力时，比如让我，像你说的，让我向你展示一些很酷的东西，对吧？但我认为这最终导致的是，特别是在像格式塔疗法这样的情况下，这里有这个美丽的理论想法，对吧？场论、对话方法、我与你、现象学、关系、中间、括号，所有这些辉煌的、非常可爱的存在主义概念，有点流入这种方法，然后我们最终得到了
oh yeah i do empty chair work therefore i'm using it and it's like ah it's like like saying like all jungian therapy is active imagination right like uh it's like let's take a technique we don't even give jungian therapy i mean actual jungians that are trained it's like it's not a time they just especially I think it's more of an American Union thing where they just sanitize it so much and they're like oh it's just therapy plus Jesus or it's like therapy you can bring to church or it's like a sand tray or like but there's not I mean the same it happens with all modalities same thing you're talking about it's like people mistake the technique for the the lens of the modality which is how you're understanding a person which is how you're the conceptualization is so much more important than what you're doing
哦，是的，我做空椅工作，因此我正在使用它，这就像，啊，这就像说所有的荣格疗法都是主动想象，对吧？就像，让我们采取一种技术，我们甚至不给荣格疗法，我的意思是受过训练的真正的荣格派，这不像是一次，他们只是，特别是我认为这更像是一种美国荣格派的事情，他们只是把它消毒得太多了，他们就像，哦，这只是治疗加耶稣，或者它就像你可以带到教堂的治疗，或者它就像一个沙盘，但没有，我的意思是，同样的事情发生在所有的模式中，你谈论的同样的事情，就像人们把技术误认为是模式的镜头，这是你理解一个人的方式，这是你如何，概念化比你正在做的事情重要得多
in the room you know i agree so fully i think and the hard part is like how do you describe being a human right like it's so potentially nuanced. The problem is psychology there, you know. Yeah, and then how do we turn this into something that creates transformative change? And I think, again, like, out of all the things that sort of Jungian slash Jung's love of alchemical ideas and that framework of thought, I think it's so beautiful because it's at least language that's not dependent on time, right? So whether it's the Taoists or Ayurvedic traditions or these different things, they're all drawing from this concept of transformation. And now my experience, especially when we're looking at things like parts work and stuff, everybody's labeled these things in their own way with their own conceptual. So much of the part, especially like IFS is like him just putting, which I don't dislike IFS.
在房间里，你知道，我完全同意，我认为困难的部分是，你如何描述成为一个人，对吧？它太微妙了。心理学的问题就在那里，你知道。是的，然后我们如何将其转化为创造变革性改变的东西？我认为，再一次，就像，在所有那些荣格/荣格对炼金术思想的热爱以及那种思想框架中，我认为它太美了，因为它至少是不依赖于时间的语言，对吧？所以无论是道家还是阿育吠陀传统，或者这些不同的东西，它们都从这个转化的概念中汲取灵感。现在我的经验，特别是当我们观察像部分工作（parts work）之类的东西时，每个人都用他们自己的概念以自己的方式标记了这些东西。很大一部分，特别是像IFS（内在家庭系统疗法），就像他只是把，我不讨厌IFS。
Like if I had a giant treatment center and I needed to train everybody to be able to do the best work, like like but like you put union archetypes together with with um gestalt therapies experiential component you know and some maybe some dbt skills but like that's what it is you know and i the language of it is kind of dogmatic you know i think it's like much easier to just say protective part you kind of feel how this one's a physical protective part that one's kind of an unconscious one or whatever then getting in a fight with a client about if something's like a firefighter or protector what like i personally like i mean it's people who do it do great work but yes you know i just i'm not as wild about the language of all that also they think it's family therapy every time you say ifs people think you're a family therapist sure they're like what
就像如果我有一个巨大的治疗中心，我需要培训每个人都能做最好的工作，就像，但就像你把荣格原型与格式塔疗法的体验式组件结合起来，你知道，还有一些DBT技能，但就像这就是它，你知道，它的语言有点教条，你知道，我认为说“保护性部分”要容易得多，你感觉到这个是一个身体保护性部分，那个是一个无意识的，或者无论什么，然后和客户争论某事是否是一个“消防员”或“保护者”，什么，我个人喜欢，我的意思是，做它的人做得很好，但是是的，你知道，我只是对所有这些语言不太感兴趣，而且他们认为每次你说IFS时，它都是家庭治疗，人们认为你是家庭治疗师，当然，他们就像，什么
do i have to bring my mother in? Well, the mother that lives in you, whether that's... She's already here. She's in the space, part of your phenomenological field. Look how we're doing this. So what did you work with Gestalt, but what are the kind of broad strokes of your practice now or the stuff that you... So, you know, I'm not an official anything, right?
我必须带我母亲来吗？嗯，活在你体内的母亲，无论那是……她已经在这里了。她在空间里，是你现象学场的一部分。看我们是怎么做这个的。那么你用格式塔工作，但你现在的实践的大致方向是什么，或者你……所以，你知道，我不是任何官方的东西，对吧？
Because unfortunately, there's a pace wall that inhibits people from becoming certified in anything and and i understand that to some degree because people want purity of systems possibly or they don't want to be misrepresented or whatever that means and that's okay and i understand that you know i think unfortunately that again diminishes the free exchange of information and ideas and then you wind up with like you said this dogmas that that have to approach existence in a very fixed pattern and that that's neurotic traditionally anyway so I would say my current I I would say the collection of things right so I do really like primarily because it makes me feel confident and science is important to people and myself, right? So the sort of neurobiological I really like polyvagal theory. I like, like I said, memory
因为不幸的是，有一堵步伐墙阻碍了人们在任何事情上获得认证，而且在某种程度上我理解这一点，因为人们可能想要系统的纯洁性，或者他们不想被歪曲，或者无论那意味着什么，这没关系，我理解这一点，你知道，我认为不幸的是，这再次削弱了信息和思想的自由交流，然后你最终得到了像你所说的这种教条，必须以一种非常固定的模式来对待存在，而且这在传统上无论如何都是神经质的，所以我说我目前的，我会说事物的集合，对吧？所以我确实非常喜欢，主要是因为它让我感到自信，科学对人们和我自己都很重要，对吧？所以那种神经生物学，我真的很喜欢多迷走神经理论。我喜欢，就像我说的，记忆
reconsolidation. I like the idea that there are fundamental processes that mammals use to make adaptation. And that just makes sense to me. And then sort of more of that, the gestalt-oriented humanistic type of thing. So kind of like Mas's low II kind of existential stuff and then I did a real deep dive into like parts work and things because if you've ever sat with anyone whether you're a therapist or otherwise you there is a there is a transition of consciousness between aspects of themselves however you want to define that right and people have been exploring that from the beginning of time. In fact, like eye movement and all of these things have been deeply analyzed by like Taoists and in ancient Arabia and like all these different kinds of things,
重构。我喜欢哺乳动物用来进行适应的基本过程的想法。这对我来说很有意义。然后是那种，格式塔导向的人文主义类型的东西。所以有点像马斯洛的第二种存在主义的东西，然后我深入研究了部分工作之类的东西，因为如果你曾经和任何人坐在一起，无论你是治疗师还是其他什么，你都会有意识在他们自己的各个方面之间转换，无论你想怎么定义它，对吧？人们从时间开始就在探索这一点。事实上，比如眼球运动和所有这些东西，已经被道家和古代阿拉伯以及所有这些不同种类的东西深入分析过，
people have been playing with human observation and how we do what we do. But one thing that constantly shows up, and I met it first in Gestalt work, right, doing empty chair, it's like, oh my gosh, what is this? We have two fundamentally different states of consciousness, and I use consciousness to define the whole being, right? It's not a thought process, but it's a total representation of self in the world, right? With environment. And it's just so fascinating there and I really, really fell in love with that and started like strongly believing in it in a sense. However, that's an interesting space to go because it's very unknown, right? Like and so I was looking for framework to understand this. And I first like got some deep framework
人们一直在玩弄人类观察以及我们如何做我们所做的事情。但有一件事不断出现，我第一次在格式塔工作中遇到它，对吧，做空椅，就像，天哪，这是什么？我们有两种根本不同的意识状态，我用意识来定义整个存在，对吧？它不是一个思维过程，但它是自我与世界在环境中的总代表，对吧？这太迷人了，我真的、真的爱上了它，并开始在某种意义上强烈地相信它。然而，这是一个有趣的探索空间，因为它非常未知，对吧？就像，所以我正在寻找框架来理解这一点。我第一次得到了某种深刻的框架
in psychosynthesis, right? Asagioli really going into all these details about sub personalities and the alchemical process of transmutation of self. And then I started kind of playing around from there. And it's interesting to see now what what my work kind of shows up as uh after I've been exposed to all these different methods voice dialogue you know internal family systems all these different ones there's a gentleman um voice dialogue have
在心理综合（Psychosynthesis）中，对吧？阿萨吉奥利（Assagioli）真的深入研究了所有关于子人格和自我嬗变的炼金过程的细节。然后我开始从那里玩起来。看到我的工作在接触了所有这些不同的方法后表现为什么样子，这很有趣，嗯，声音对话（Voice Dialogue），你知道，内在家庭系统，所有这些不同的，有一位先生，嗯，声音对话有
like purchase out there I mean it seems like there's not a ton of places still doing it much. So I had to look to find all of these things, right? Ego states is super fun, enjoyable for folks because it derives from our currently utilized processes that are popular. That's like the last remnant of transactional analysis that's still out there. Yeah, no, absolutely. Yeah, like this, which all have roots in this gestalt thing which all have roots in you know
像那样的购买力，我的意思是，看起来并没有很多地方还在做它。所以我不得不寻找才能找到所有这些东西，对吧？自我状态（Ego states）对人们来说超级有趣、令人愉快，因为它源于我们目前使用的、流行的过程。那是交易分析（Transactional Analysis）中仍然存在的最后残余。是的，不，绝对是。是的，像这样，所有这些都植根于这个格式塔的东西，所有这些都植根于，你知道
psychoanalytic processes right in ego and super ego are parts right I mean to find them how you will there there's something right yeah yeah and so I think finding out how to work with parts and also my own processes looked like working with parts and also realizing more process has looked like working with parts and also realizing more of this kind of, again, this field oriented idea or kind of this Buddhist idea of this non-local, non-duality. So it's like parts and no parts can both mutually exist. And what's meaningful is how it applies in the field of exchange in that moment with the person. At least that's kind of where I'm sitting at. I'm kind of wondering for yourself, how have you integrated
精神分析过程，对吧？自我和超我都是部分，对吧？我的意思是，随你怎么定义它们，它们就在那里，对吧？是的，是的，所以我认为找出如何与部分一起工作，以及我自己的过程看起来像是与部分一起工作，以及意识到更多，我的过程看起来像是与部分一起工作，以及意识到更多这种，再一次，这种场导向的想法，或者这种佛教的非局部、非二元性的想法。所以就像部分和没有部分可以同时存在。有意义的是它在那个时刻与人交流的场中是如何应用的。至少这就是我所处的位置。我有点好奇你自己，你是如何整合
that? Do you stick kind of like sharply to a process of the way of working with parts or how have you integrated this? Because you have a lot of really cool neurobiological techniques, right? And then you have this other stuff too. I'm kind of like, I'm very curious about that. Well, I i mean i think probably what you're responding to is when i'm looking at the way that a lot of these models are written you know younger pearls or whatever i mean they're written in phenomenological language it's like this is just how this feels yes um and and so they're kind of intuitive which is the reason why a lot of people, they won't die. A lot of people are called back to them and a lot of reasons why they're never going to be institutionally there is that they're not,
那个的？你是坚持某种与部分一起工作的过程，还是你是如何整合这个的？因为你有很多非常酷的神经生物学技术，对吧？然后你还有这些其他的东西。我有点，我对那个非常好奇。嗯，我，我的意思是，我认为你可能正在回应的是，当我观察这些模型被编写的方式时，你知道，荣格或珀尔斯或什么的，我的意思是，它们是用现象学语言编写的，就像这只是感觉如何，是的，嗯，所以它们有点直观，这就是为什么很多人，它们不会死。很多人被召回它们，很多原因它们永远不会在制度上存在，是因为它们不是，
it's not an objective thing. It's kind of an intuitive concept about, don't you understand this part of your own experience? You know, if you're chasing the academic thing and you don't understand that part of your experience, that's not going to speak to you, you know, because it's not, it's not real. You can't see it, taste it, touch it. This is a subjective kind of felt state in the parts of self that you can feel and work with um and i mean frankly i think to do certain kinds of trauma therapy you have to bury a certain kind
它不是一个客观的东西。它是一种关于“你不理解你自己体验的这一部分吗？”的直观概念。你知道，如果你在追求学术的东西，而你不理解你体验的那一部分，那将不会对你说话，你知道，因为它不是，它不是真实的。你看不到它，尝不到它，摸不到它。这是一种主观的、感觉到的状态，在你能够感受和工作的自我部分中，嗯，而且坦率地说，我认为要做某些类型的创伤治疗，你必须埋葬某种
of trauma that you've worked through um you don't really understand it yeah and but then now you know there's neurology and neurobiology that is able to explain, we can make guesses, you know, I'll still get like a nasty email from a clinical psychology student, but like we can make guesses about what these parts of the brain do. And that's always been my interest. And so it's like, cause I was always frustrated with just how much,
你已经解决的创伤，嗯，你并不真正理解它，是的，但现在你知道有神经学和神经生物学能够解释，我们可以猜测，你知道，我仍然会收到临床心理学学生的讨厌邮件，但就像我们可以猜测大脑的这些部分做什么。这一直是我感兴趣的。所以就像，因为我一直对学术界承认自己错误的能力有多差感到沮丧。就像发表这些论文的是同一群人，他们就像，你知道，荣格，不，无意识不是真实的，这是无论什么，是的，现在创伤很时髦，所以同一个人就像写了一篇论文，说，好吧，有第三、第二和第一层次的意识，但第三层次只是，你知道，符号功能，并出现在身体里，你就像，什么伙计，就像你错了，只是，只是写，我很抱歉，你知道，那是你应该发表的论文，但是，你知道，你只是，所以我的事情是回去
how, how bad academia is admitting that it's wrong. Like it's the same people publishing these papers that are like you know jung doesn't no unconscious isn't real and this is whatever yeah now trauma is trendy so the same guy is like writing a paper that's like well there's tertiary secondary and primary levels of consciousness but the tertiary levels are only you know symbolic function and show up in the body and you're like what dude like you're you're wrong just just right i'm sorry you know that's the paper that you should be publishing um but you know you're you're just so my thing is going
并说，看，是的，这些哲学是永恒的，意味着它们独立出现，因为人们在某种程度上感受自己并发现了关于我们如何运作的同样的事情。但后来很多时候，我真的在任何地方都没有朋友，因为我说，我不仅仅在这个俱乐部里。我试图说，所有这些俱乐部都共享功能，而且它们都不是，它们都有利有弊。它们都有缺点。人们不喜欢那样。他们喜欢我，因为我说的程度是，好吧，你正在做的事情很有趣，这里有一个很酷的表达方式，这里有一些技术，他们喜欢那个，然后我说，好吧，但这就是局限性所在，以及如果你，哦不，不要，不要那样做，你知道，这就是，你知道
back and saying look yeah these these philosophies are perennial meaning they pop up independently because there's people sort of feeling themselves and discovering the same thing about how we work. But then a lot of times, I don't really have a friend anywhere because I'm saying, I'm not just in this club. I'm trying to say that all these clubs share functions and that neither one of them is, they all have pros and cons. They all have drawbacks. People don't like that. They like me for the extent of me saying, well, this is what you're doing is interesting and here's a cool way to articulate it and here's some techniques there they like that and then i say okay but here's where the limitations are and where you can pivot if oh no don't don't do that you know and that's that's the you know
人们有点喜欢网上的东西，直到他们不喜欢，你知道，我有时甚至没有机会回复邮件，这就像，哦，这太棒了，我用了它，这太棒了，我用了它，哦等等，你说了这件对我的实践方式有威胁的事情，所以我认为你不明白，就像我还没说什么呢，我不知道，你知道，嗯，我不知道这是否回答了它，但你知道那个视频，我谈论我如何认为这些模型的崩溃就像它们有多么体验式，以及它们有多么认知，所以那个进来并说他们想要存在主义治疗的人，他们就像，我不知道我在萨特（Sartre）的博士学位，你说存在主义治疗，我被召唤到无论什么，我在脑海里想，那是
people kind of like the stuff online until they don't you know i won't even get a chance to respond to the email sometimes it's just like oh this is great and i used it and this is great i used it oh wait you said this thing that's threatening to the way that i practice so i don't think you understand like i haven't said anything yet like i don't know you know um i don't know if that answers it but you know that video that i have where i'm talking about like how i think the breakdown of these models is like how experiential they are and how cognitive they are and so the person who comes in and says that they want existential therapy and they're like i didn't know my phd in sartre and you said existential therapy and i'm called to whatever i'm like in the back of my head i'm like that's the
你最不需要的东西，你知道，对吧，并不是其他人是地狱，而是你身处地狱，因为你感觉不好，就像，你不需要，你知道，对于那个完全处于感觉状态和感受中的人也是一样，所有这些都是真实的。他们想倾倒所有这些情绪。我的意思是，真正你需要的是跳出那个状态，看到更大的图景，并拥有某种，你知道，精神或哲学的镜头来分析你的生活。嗯，Yalom在他的书中确实说了这一点，你进来想要的治疗通常是你最不需要的那一种。这就是荣格的对立面功能，对吧？或者这种对立面的张力，是的。
last thing that you need you know right it's not that other people are are hell it's that you are in hell because you feel bad like and you you don't need to you know and the same thing with the person who comes in that's just totally in their feeling state and their feelings, all it's real. And they want to dump all this emotion. I mean, really what you need is to kind of get outside of that and see a bigger picture and have some kind of, you know, spiritual or philosophical ones to analyze your life. Um, which Yalom says that in his book, that the kind of therapy you come in wanting is usually the last one that you need. And it's that Jungian function of opposites, right? Or this tension of opposites, yeah.
是的，就像，好吧，是的，我们想以这种方式进来。所以很可能另一面才是我们最可能获得最大收益的地方。然而，我们如何让你感到舒适地走进那个空间？因为我们必须建立结构和一些不同的脚手架来踏入未知，对吧？
Yeah, it's like, okay, yeah, we want to come in this way. So it's likely that the other side of that is probably where we're going to get the most yield. However, how do we get you to feel comfortable walking into that space? Because we have to build structure and some different scaffolding to step into the unknown, right?
所以如果我加载了某种视角，我很容易走进那个世界，直到我把脚趾浸入我不感知的现实中，然后就像，哦，天哪，然后我们得到了所有适应的功能，比如，哦，那威胁到了我的自我概念，所有这些，是的，嗯，我的意思是，如果你只是听冲突或政治，或者你知道无论什么，就像人们陷入的一半争吵，或者他们变得最反动的地方，只是有人说，嘿，我的行为与我的自我形象不符，而你指出了这一点，
So if I am like loaded with a certain perspective, it's easy for me to walk in that world until i dip my toe in the reality that i don't perceive then it's like oh my goodness and then we get all of the functions of like adaptation like oh that threatens my self concept and all this yeah well i mean that's if you just listen to conflict or politics or you know whatever it's like half of the half of the the fights that people get into or where they become the most reactive is just where somebody's saying hey my behavior doesn't line up with my self-image and you're pointing that out to me
你知道，这就像我能做治疗但可能做不好其他任何事情的原因之一，就是我从来没有停止那样做，如果你说了什么，我会按字面意思理解，正因为如此，你知道，人们进入治疗，对那个过程有一种认同，比如，但你知道，这让你在感恩节时成为一个令人讨厌的人。也许我们到时候会放弃这一集。当我在医院时，就像我无法关掉它。我的意思是，他们会有这种事情，他们就像，嘿，
you know which is like one of the reasons why i can do therapy but probably not anything else very well is that i don't quit doing that ever um if you say something i'm going to take it at face value and because of that know, people come into therapy, there's kind of a buy-in to that process of like, but you know, it makes you a miserable person to be around at Thanksgiving. Maybe we'll drop this episode then. When I was in a hospital, like I couldn't turn it off. I mean, they would have this thing where they're like, Hey,
我们真的想持续改进，我们想知道问题是什么，我们想要你们所有的投入，我们想要你们诚实，然后我会说，好吧，那么这里有一件你可以轻松做到的事情，可以为你省钱，减少倦怠，减少错误，而缺点是它可能会威胁到某人的自尊，或者我们只需要承认有一个问题，这正是你所要求的，哦，哦，不，不，别那样说。那不是你应该做的。好吧，没问题。那么你并不想要你所说的。所以不要开这个会。就像每六个月给我三个小时的生命，或者说，我想要你给我诚实的反馈，你知道我的意思吗？只要你在说，我就会继续按字面意思理解，即使我
we really want to continuously improve and we want to know what the problem is and we want your all input and we want you to be honest and then i'd be like okay well then here's a thing that you could do easily that would save you money and it would make reduce burnout and it would reduce errors and the downside is it might threaten somebody's ego or we would just have to admit that there's a problem which is what you're asking oh Oh, no, no, don't say that. That's not what you're supposed to. Okay, fine. Then you don't want what you said. So don't do this meeting. Like give me three hours of my life every six months or say, I want you to give me your honest feedback where it's, you know what I mean? Like, as long as you're saying it, I'm going to continue to take it at face value, even though I
知道你不是那个意思。而且我不会停止那样做。我的意思是，这就是我所要做的。这就是现象学方法，对吧？就像你字面上不可能知道除了当下正在发生的事情之外的任何事情，对吧？就像其他一切都是推断或某种投射之类的东西。所以就像，好吧，这就是你的意思，对吧？他们说，不。好吧，所以这不是你的意思。但这就是你所说的。那是正确的吗？我喜欢那个。我喜欢这种记忆重构，就像基本的初始租户只是创造这种明确的意识，然后是一种并置，比如，所以这个和这个，是的。
know you don't mean what you're saying. And I'm not going to stop doing that. I mean, that's all that I'm going to do. And that's the phenomenological approach, right? Like you literally cannot know anything other than what is happening in the immediate now, right? It's like everything else is extrapolation or some sort of like projection or something. So it's like, okay, this is what you mean, right? And they're like, no. Okay, so this is not what you mean. But this is what you're saying. Is that correct? And I love that. I love that this memory reconsolidation, like the fundamental initial tenant is just creating this explicit awareness and then a juxtaposition of like, so this and this, yes.
你能为可能不熟悉的人谈谈记忆重构，那个技术吗？是的，绝对。让我们看看。所以Ecker，Bruce Ecker，Lauren Holy。所以Bruce Ecker在开始进入整个治疗情况之前是一名物理学家。而且，你知道，我喜欢人们有激情，因为激情创造了，就像他们把人们带入虫洞，导致我永远找不到的信息，因为我的激情不倾向于那个方向。
Can you talk a little bit about memory reconsolidation for people that may not be familiar that that the technique there? Yeah, absolutely. Let's see. So Ecker, Bruce Ecker, Lauren Holy. So Bruce Ecker was a physicist before he started getting into the whole therapy situation. And, you know, I love that people have passions because passions create like they take people down wormholes that lead to information I would never find because my passion doesn't lean in that direction.
所以他们确实做了很多工作，研究这种我们如何从根本上改变我们的记忆的想法，对吧？直到2000年代初左右，有一种想法是，一旦它进入长期记忆存储，你就被困住了，对吧？直到2000年代初左右，有一种想法是，一旦它进入长期记忆存储，你就被困住了，对吧？甚至我们在Van der Kolk的书里也有，比如《身体从未忘记》（The Body Keeps the Score）。就像，不，一旦它进去了，它就在那里，你被困住了。然后这导致，对吧？这需要创造过程，我们在做策略的反向发展，对吧？所以我们正在寻找消退（extinction），这就像，让我建立这个神经通路，它是
And so they really did a lot of work looking at this idea of how we fundamentally change our memories, right? There was this idea up until like the early 2000s or so that once it's in long-term memory storage, you're stuck with it, right? There was this idea up until like the early 2000s or so that once it's in long-term memory storage, you're stuck with it, right? And even we have in Van der Kolk's book, like the body keeps the score. It's like, no, once it's in there, it's in there, you're stuck. And then that leads, right? That necessitates creating processes where we're doing a counter development of a strategy, right? So we're looking for extinction, which is like, let me build up this neurological pathway that's
与这个相反的，这样它们就可以战斗。希望我的前额叶皮层在受到威胁时能战胜我的边缘系统和皮层下区域。我们可以通过一些脱敏和建立策略来做到这一点，对吧？这很好。而且建立策略也是我们学习、成长和发展的方式。然而，当我访问我存在的历史片段时，情感痛苦的基本感觉，那不是很有趣。而这正是驱动我们大多数人寻求改变的原因。而且这个想法真的很可爱，因为他们遵循这个模型，就像你不能擦除长期记忆，一旦它进去了，它就在那里，然后哇，各种酷的实验，他们正在使用老鼠，然后
contrary to this one so they can battle it out. And hopefully my prefrontal cortex wins down against my limbic system and my subcortical areas when I'm threatened. And we can do that through some desensitization and building up strategies, right? Which is fine. And that also building strategies is how we learn, grow and develop. However, the fundamental sense of emotional pain when I access a historical piece of my existence, that's not very fun. And that's what drives most of us to seek change. And this idea is really lovely because they were going off this model like you can't erase long-term memory once it's in it's in and then whoa all sorts of cool experiments they're using mice and then
与此相反，这样它们就可以一决高下。希望当受到威胁时，我的前额叶皮层能战胜我的边缘系统和皮层下区域。我们可以通过一些脱敏和建立策略来做到这一点，对吧？这很好。而建立策略也是我们学习、成长和发展的方式。然而，当我接触到我生命中一段过往经历时，那种根本性的情感痛苦感并不好受。而这正是驱使我们大多数人寻求改变的原因。这个想法真的很棒，因为他们基于这样一个模型：一旦进入长期记忆就无法抹除，然后哇，他们正在用老鼠进行各种很酷的实验，然后
they're putting in certain chemicals that inhibit the consolidation of certain kinds of neurological processes and bada-boom bada bang. Now we, we're not having the long-term memory affect them on an emotional level, but they still theoretically hold on to that information in a chronological fashion. Right. So, and anything like with brain science, cause there are, you know, billions of connections is going to be reduced to some kind of metaphor. I mean, there's no way to talk about it without being reductive unless you're a supercomputer, you know, but I mean, that's another another thing a lot of the research is showing is the parasympathetic and the sympathetic nervous system are out of sync they're not acting in the same way which i mean to me with brain spotting and ett and a lot of the pupil dilation stuff that we do
他们放入某些化学物质来抑制某些神经过程的巩固，然后砰的一声。现在，我们不会让长期记忆在情感层面上影响他们，但从理论上讲，他们仍然以时间顺序保留了这些信息。对。所以，就像脑科学中的任何事物一样，因为有数十亿个连接，它会被简化为某种隐喻。我的意思是，除非你是超级计算机，否则如果不进行简化，就无法谈论它，但我的意思是，这是研究显示的另一件事，即副交感神经系统和交感神经系统不同步，它们的作用方式不一致，对我来说，通过脑点疗法（Brainspotting）、ETT（情感转化疗法）以及我们所做的许多瞳孔放大相关的工作
you can't fake those reactions you know when people's like doing this you're you know you're having a brain bleed where you're maybe brain spotting works and it's doing something that's neurologically reproducible with a reproducible effect. Even if it's not plastazillion randomized controlled trials and isn't 30 years old yet, you know, something I can recreate in the room. I hear the same thing from the patient that cures the same thing. You know, that's how science works. Even it starts it starts here you know um you research it later and um and there are a lot of studies on it now being more effective than emdr and some other things but the parasympathetic and sympathetic
你无法伪装这些反应，你知道，当人们这样做时，你可能会出现脑出血，也许脑点疗法有效，它正在做一些神经学上可重现的事情，并产生可重现的效果。即使它不是成千上万次随机对照试验，也不是已经存在了30年，你知道，这是我可以在诊室里重现的东西。我从病人那里听到同样的事情，治愈同样的事情。你知道，科学就是这样运作的。即使它从这里开始，你知道，嗯，你以后再研究它，而且现在有很多关于它的研究，认为它比EMDR（眼动脱敏再加工）和其他一些东西更有效，但副交感神经和交感神经
nervous system fighting each other one dilates the eye it has kind of a sphincter like muscle that tightens and the other one has a pulling muscle that opens the eye sorry i hit my mic um and that when you usually don't drive with your foot on the gas and the brake. Right. But what I can do is hit those to be in tension, you know, with color, light, frequency, eye position. You know, all the different techniques that we have now, eye movement sometimes until they re-sync. And my body is assuming the same thing that the front of my brain is assuming about how the world works not something that is 15 years old you know traumatic i love that and and this even speaks to like um peter levine the oscillation felt senses right even going back to um earlier
神经系统相互对抗，一个使眼睛放大，它有一种类似括约肌的肌肉会收紧，另一个有拉动肌肉使眼睛张开，抱歉，我碰到了麦克风，嗯，通常你不会在踩油门的同时踩刹车。对。但我能做的是通过颜色、光线、频率、眼睛位置来让它们处于紧张状态。你知道，我们现在拥有的所有不同技术，有时是眼球运动，直到它们重新同步。我的身体假设的东西和我大脑前部对世界运作方式的假设是一样的，而不是15年前的创伤，我喜欢这一点，这甚至谈到了彼得·莱文（Peter Levine）的振荡感官，对吧，甚至回溯到更早的
stuff of self-observation we're looking at like gendlin eugene gendlin in this focusing right like here is a felt sense i experience it i look i put words on it and then there's this curious thing I'm speaking back to this memory reconsolidation piece which I love because it's non-theoretical right it's it it is theoretical in the scientific sense but it's trans theoretical in the sense that it doesn't belong to anybody nobody can yeah you know this is my method you can't reconsolidate memory only I can do that right I have it all it's mine let pay me thousands of dollars to learn my strategy which is fine it is kind of even the models that I like it's kind of
关于自我观察的东西，我们正在看像尤金·根德林（Eugene Gendlin）的聚焦疗法，就像这里有一种感官体验，我体验它，我观察，我用语言描述它，然后有一件奇怪的事情，我正在谈论这个记忆重巩固的部分，我喜欢它，因为它不是理论性的，对吧，它在科学意义上是理论性的，但它是跨理论的，因为它不属于任何人，没有人能说“这是我的方法，你不能重巩固记忆，只有我能做到”，对吧，我拥有这一切，它是我的，付给我几千美元来学习我的策略，这很好，它甚至是我喜欢的模型，它也有点
off-putting or they're like look you use this word then you're you know whatever it's like man come on like why are you doing this like well they we have to and some because it's marking territory and it's validating philosophical processes and trying to differentiate that from something else and all the things. So what I love though, and I'm very curious, especially with brain spotting and various other eye movement type things, whether it's NLP and the different ways of accessing or looking in the visual field or any of these things, or
令人反感，或者他们说“看，你用了这个词，然后你，你知道，无论如何”，就像“伙计，拜托，你为什么要这样做”，好吧，他们必须这样做，因为这是在划分地盘，验证哲学过程，并试图将其与别的东西区分开来，以及所有这些事情。但我喜欢的是，我非常好奇，特别是在脑点疗法和各种其他眼动类型的事情上，无论是NLP（神经语言程序学）还是在视觉领域访问或观察的不同方式，或者任何这些事情，或者
even just staying with the micro tremors and Neurogenic tremoring that happens during certain kinds of activation all the good stuff, right? Mm-hmm the lovely thing about this This idea. So the concept here for the memory reconsolidation is that it is theoretically the way So not and and sometimes that feels kind of powerful, but it is the way of creating And sometimes that feels kind of powerful, but it is the way of creating forever emotional change. And the way that it works is memory is consolidated during event of high emotion, right? So boom, I have stored that in my system. However we do that, we have no clue, right? We have all these ideas on how memory works, but it's way too integrative to just be reduced to like neurons.
甚至只是保持微震颤和在某些激活过程中发生的神经源性震颤，所有这些好东西，对吧？嗯，关于这个想法的美妙之处。所以这里关于记忆重巩固的概念是，它在理论上是这种方式，所以不是，有时这感觉很有力量，但它是创造永久情感改变的方式。它的工作原理是记忆在高度情绪化的事件中被巩固，对吧？所以砰的一声，我把它存储在我的系统中了。无论我们如何做到这一点，我们都毫无头绪，对吧？我们对记忆如何运作有所有这些想法，但它太综合了，不能仅仅简化为神经元。
It's yeah. So memory is stored with emotion. Right. In order to change that, the process is really, really simple, but it's also challenging because the process is this. I need to activate that as a felt experience, that memory with the emotional component. Once I activate that memory in a felt experience, I need to create an explicit juxtaposition is the word that they use. Something that fundamentally on a felt sense disconfirms the fact that that is. Whatever that might be, whether that's I'm using an eye thing and I'm in a safe space or whatever that is. And what that does is it unlocks all of the patterns of how that's held. Because now, just like an animal, right, I have an explicit fact that contradicts the emotional content.
是的。所以记忆是伴随着情绪存储的。对。为了改变这一点，过程非常非常简单，但也具有挑战性，因为过程是这样的：我需要将其激活为一种感官体验，即带有情感成分的记忆。一旦我将该记忆激活为感官体验，我就需要创建一个明确的并置，这是他们使用的词。在感官上从根本上反驳了事实的东西。无论那可能是什么，无论我是在使用眼部动作还是处于一个安全的空间，或者无论那是什么。而这所做的是解锁了它被持有的所有模式。因为现在，就像动物一样，对吧，我有一个明确的事实与情感内容相矛盾。
And once that opens, then we have a process of five hour window where if we continually repeat the disconfirming event, when it consolidates, the evidence says that what should happen is that should no longer elicit anything you can call it back up and it will be a historical piece of information but it will not be emotional uh charged to it it sounds like a lifespan integration is doing that too i'm not trained in that one you. I've read the book and one of my supervision candidates is really into it. But it sounds similar in that you're kind of taking these things that are felt experiential, pretty strong activating memories, but they are contradictory. And then ramming them all through so quickly that you can't continue to have all of that stored somatic memory be unchallenged and then the brain guy lets it go. And that life the timeline and lifespan stuff is really
一旦它打开，我们就会有一个五小时的窗口期，如果我们不断重复这个反驳事件，当它巩固时，证据表明应该发生的是，它不再引起任何东西，你可以把它调出来，它将是一条历史信息，但它不会有情感上的负担。听起来寿命整合（Lifespan Integration）也在做同样的事情，我没有接受过那方面的培训。我读过那本书，我的一位督导候选人非常喜欢它。但听起来很相似，你是在把这些感官体验到的、相当强烈的激活记忆拿出来，但它们是矛盾的。然后把它们如此迅速地全部塞进去，以至于你不能继续让所有这些存储的躯体记忆不受挑战，然后大脑就会放手。而那个生命时间线和寿命的东西真的
interesting because we look at NLP they've been using timelines and things for a long long long time right and this is one of the other things that I struggle with is people will take ideas that are explicitly described in older therapeutic modalities they will not give credit to the line of thinking, and they will attribute it to their own process. That is one of the things. Well, and then sometimes they don't even know when they're doing it. I mean, you can kind of tell when people know that they're doing it
很有趣，因为我们看NLP，他们使用时间线和事物已经很长很长很长时间了，对吧，这是我挣扎的另一件事，人们会采用在旧治疗模式中明确描述的想法，他们不会归功于那种思维方式，他们会将其归因于他们自己的过程。这是其中之一。嗯，有时他们甚至不知道自己在做什么。我的意思是，你可以看出人们什么时候知道自己在做这件事
and when people don't. You know, like Joseph Campbell bringing Jung to America. I mean, I feel like he knew what he was stealing, and he was a Jungian, and he didn't give credit to him. He said that you know but um yeah there's other people where i think they've just heard something and then they start doing something and then they decide they can you know what i mean like the yeah yeah that's fair uh what i really what i really love though about this process so this idea memory recall it somatically in a felt way, juxtaposition of experience, something that completely explicitly confronts that, create the unlock, which then allows new information to be encoded and the memory to go away. this is very dependent on each situation. So you can remove the emotional charge of a certain
什么时候不知道。你知道，就像约瑟夫·坎贝尔（Joseph Campbell）把荣格（Jung）带到美国。我的意思是，我觉得他知道自己在偷什么，他是一个荣格主义者，但他没有归功于他。他说你知道，但嗯，是的，还有其他人，我想他们只是听到了什么，然后他们就开始做某事，然后他们决定他们可以，你知道我的意思吗，就像是的，是的，这很公平，嗯，我真正喜欢这个过程的是，这个记忆回溯的想法，以感官的方式，体验的并置，某种完全明确地对抗它的东西，创造解锁，然后允许新信息被编码，记忆消失。这非常依赖于每种情况。所以你可以消除某种东西的情感负担，
thing, but if it has other connections or other parts are attached to it, each of those would also need to go through this process of reconciliation, in order to get the full effect of, when I think of that in this, this, this, this, this context, it no longer elicits that strong, necessary emotional survival response. And what I like about it is because it's kind of like just a concept neurologically, it means that every therapeutic modality could theoretically work. And if they worked, it means they followed this natural biological process and if what i really love about concepts like that is that it's it gives a lot of
但如果它有其他连接或有其他部分附着在它上面，每一个都需要经过这个重巩固过程，才能获得完整的效果，即当我在此情境下思考它时，它不再引起那种强烈的、必要的生存情感反应。我喜欢它是因为它在神经学上就像一个概念，这意味着每种治疗模式在理论上都可能有效。如果它们有效，意味着它们遵循了这个自然的生物过程，如果我真正喜欢像这样的概念，是因为它给了临床医生很多
freedom back to the clinician to trust their their artfulness their own intuition their intuition yeah so it says okay this is generally how it works even if you was polyvagal theory i think was also beautiful for that this is generally how it works now knowing that within the confines of the biology let's let's use our creative playful curiosity to generate new outcomes yeah well and that's the thing that you can't teach you know it's like i love it if there's an interview candidate that fights with me because they understand something and they believe it and they know something they're not just trying to figure out what somebody wants from them those are the clinicians that take years to get better the ones that are coming from the hospital or something and like it's almost like they were trained not to think for themselves and justify everything they do in this thing and you know
自由去信任他们的艺术性和直觉。是的，所以它说，好吧，这通常就是它的工作方式，即使你使用多迷走神经理论，我认为这也很好，这通常就是它的工作方式，现在知道在生物学的范围内，让我们利用我们创造性的、好玩的、好奇心来产生新的结果。是的，这就是你无法教的东西，你知道，如果有一个面试候选人因为他们理解某事、相信它并且知道某事而与我争论，我会很高兴，他们不仅仅是在试图弄清楚别人想要他们做什么，那些是需要几年时间才能变得更好的临床医生，那些来自医院或类似地方的人，几乎就像他们被训练成不要独立思考，并为他们所做的一切辩护，你知道
like the question that you can't fake in an interview you know if you're uh if you're early in your therapy education remember this one i mean just absorb a ton of podcasts and a ton of like current material on that and then go in with like a fresh perspective and be like this is where i think it's headed this is where it's not because you can't fake that question i mean when the when we do like executive coaching and people are talking about hiring like i always mentioned like just ask them the last thing that they learned independently that they applied to their job if somebody's telling you about what they learned in college 20 years ago don't hire them if they're like well i kind of think this and i think this way even if it's coding it doesn't have to be therapy because you can't teach curiosity, pretty good indicator of one, you know, self-awareness,
就像面试中你无法伪装的问题，你知道，如果你在治疗教育的早期，记住这一点，我的意思是，吸收大量的播客和大量关于此的当前材料，然后带着新鲜的视角进去，说“这就是我认为它要去的地方，这就是它不去的地方”，因为你无法伪装那个问题，我的意思是，当我们做高管教练，人们谈论招聘时，我总是提到，问他们最近独立学习并应用到工作中的东西。如果有人告诉你他们20年前在大学里学到了什么，不要雇佣他们。如果他们说“嗯，我有点这样想，我这样想”，即使是编程，也不一定是治疗，因为你无法教好奇心，这是一个很好的指标，你知道，自我意识，
um, uh, a conscious relationship with intuition and, uh, a drive to be better, which is what you want, which is what you want in the room. You know?
嗯，与直觉的自觉关系，以及变得更好的动力，这正是你想要的，这正是你在诊室里想要的。你知道吗？
I, and I love, I like that, that phrase. He said, curiosity can't be taught. And that other thing, because it can't be taught,
我，我喜欢那个短语。他说，好奇心是教不会的。还有那件事，因为它教不会，
it means that it's a biological function. This is that like ventral vagal thing it's like and and everyone uses different languaging higher self maybe the self or these things but the neat thing is i think it can be healed you know i'm not saying that some people are born with it and some people aren't it's genetic i'm saying that like your relationship to your trauma and your life and your sense of self that is a really good indicator of whether or not those things are in a good place, you know, because a ton of people, you know, it's like a ton of people who that's why E I N F J types are so dangerous. You know, you get, you get Jesus and you also get Hiller like, you know,
这意味着它是一种生物功能。这就是那种腹侧迷走神经的东西，每个人都使用不同的语言，也许是高我，也许是自我，或者这些东西，但妙处在于，我认为它可以被治愈，你知道，我不是说有些人天生就有，有些人没有，它是遗传的，我是说，你与创伤、生活和自我感的关系，是判断这些事情是否处于良好状态的一个很好的指标，你知道，因为很多人，你知道，这就是为什么INFJ类型的人如此危险。你知道，你会得到耶稣，也会得到希特勒，你知道，
because your, your intuition is so strong in order to like see what people want to hear and then get them in their own language to go somewhere which can make you really capable as a therapist but also as a co-leader and a lot of those people who are doing i mean some are grifters but a lot of the people who are doing bad work like it's not that they're um meaning to it's that they're mistaking trauma for intuition because they come from the same part of the brain and they're they're actually having this trauma response but it feels like i'm the spirit's in me and i'm giving the sermon
因为你的直觉太强了，为了看人们想听什么，然后用他们自己的语言让他们去某个地方，这可以让你作为一个治疗师非常有能力，但也作为共同领导者，很多做这些事的人，我的意思是有些人是骗子，但很多做糟糕工作的人，并不是他们有意为之，而是他们把创伤误认为是直觉，因为它们来自大脑的同一部分，他们实际上有这种创伤反应，但感觉就像“精神在我里面，我正在布道”。
i don't know and like the early days of charismatic christianity in the old west i mean it really was wild that it was just like up in the mountains everybody with a dopamine disorder needs they've got the calling now let's people would scream and cry and see things and lay on the ground and and and buttoned up victorian society was like this slaps man like this is the coolest thing like i'm you know and they were feeling something like yes yeah that's but you know you want your intuition to be conscious is the point you know yeah i like that and i i think that um like being, and even speaking to that piece, right? The neat thing is that humans, when given a safe container and given permission to be appropriately expressive and to feel,
我不知道，就像美国西部早期灵恩派基督教的日子，我的意思是，这真的很疯狂，就像在山上，每个有多巴胺障碍的人都需要，他们现在有了召唤，现在让人们尖叫、哭泣、看到东西、躺在地上，而保守的维多利亚社会就像“这太棒了，伙计，这是最酷的事情”，你知道，他们感觉到了什么，是的，是的，但你知道，重点是你希望你的直觉是自觉的，你知道，是的，我喜欢这一点，而且我认为，嗯，就像成为，甚至谈到那部分，对吧？妙处在于，人类在给予一个安全的容器并被允许适当地表达和感受时，
especially with others, because we do all this really cool neurological connection, you know, this mirror neurons and the distribution of like emotional tension, whether that's electromagnetic through whatever that is, as we're doing all that fun stuff or whatever but the neat thing is when we have a community of people that are coming together with a and ideally with full intention and understanding of what they're doing and then they create a space for exchange and support man those are the the most beautiful healing environments the temnos right this container yeah that was the title of will salmon's book about the spirituality of urban planning a guy he was on our podcast earlier he's a really nice guy you know the tenemos is the
特别是与他人在一起时，因为我们做了所有这些非常酷的神经连接，你知道，这些镜像神经元和情感张力的分布，无论是通过电磁还是其他什么，当我们做所有那些有趣的事情时，或者无论如何，但妙处在于，当我们有一个社区的人聚集在一起，理想情况下，带着充分的意图和对他们正在做的事情的理解，然后他们创造了一个交流和支持的空间，伙计，那是，最美丽的治愈环境，Temenos（圣域），这个容器，是的，那是威尔·萨蒙（Will Salmon）关于城市规划灵性的书名，他之前在我们的播客上，他是一个非常好的人，你知道，Temenos是
that's the name guys and the thing i think the disempowering part of information right in some respects I think like it is theoretically it's neutered right it's just information and we have the freedom to connect with that but though another battle that I fought one of my own like internal oppressors or call it what you will right it's like trying to do things the right way you know and I've I've been in enough reduces anxiety if there the right way, you know, and I've I've been in enough. It reduces anxiety if there's a right way, you know, and and therapy gets to a point where somebody is being like, no, I know that you don't know. I know it's up to me, but I'm worried that I'm doing me wrong.
那是名字，伙计们，我认为信息中削弱力量的部分，在某些方面，我认为它在理论上是被阉割的，对吧，它只是信息，我们有自由去连接它，但这是我与我自己的内部压迫者之一进行的另一场战斗，或者随你怎么称呼它，对吧，就像试图以正确的方式做事，你知道，如果有一种正确的方式，它会减少焦虑，你知道，而且我经历过足够多了。如果有一种正确的方式，它会减少焦虑，你知道，治疗到了一个地步，有人说，不，我知道你不知道。我知道这取决于我，但我担心我做错了。
You know, and it is this thing that it's such a silly idea or a silly statement, but it's a real thing. And that we have this insecurity about if we're doing us right. You know, I mean, I had somebody one time that told me, okay, yeah, you're saying that if I get rid of this, then I'll sit down. I'll know exactly who I am and I'll be able to connect with people in a way that's good. And, and, but what if I do that? And I don't like you. That guy is, I just started laughing. It's just like, what am I, what am I supposed to say?
你知道，这是一个如此愚蠢的想法或愚蠢的陈述，但它是一件真实的事情。我们对我们是否做得正确有这种不安全感。你知道，我的意思是，有一次有人告诉我，好吧，是的，你说如果我摆脱了这个，那么我会坐下来。我会确切地知道我是谁，我将能够以一种好的方式与人联系。而且，但是如果我那样做了呢？我不喜欢你。那个人，我只是开始笑。这就像，我该说什么？
And what if I like myself and the self that I am right now is rebuttals by the self that it could be in the future if I hold my potential? It's like, but it's so human. It makes a ton of sense. It's not like that person. I'm not making fun of them. I'm just saying like we all do that. You're right. Yes.
如果我喜欢我自己，而现在的我被未来的我所反驳，如果我保持我的潜力呢？这就像，但这太人性化了。这很有道理。那个人并不是那样。我不是在取笑他们。我只是说我们都这样做。你是对的。是的。
I just never heard it said. I don't like that guy. I don't like the authentic me and I think the the challenge with all of these like structured ways of having to be or trying to get it right and somebody saying I have the way and all of this stuff you know it the things that I think get hamstrung by those things in particular are the power of our own in impressive creativity, the beauty of our intuition. And then the other thing is this, and I think this is something that earlier, Young and some of the Schultes and folks, the aesthetic value of beauty and felt sense,
我只是从来没听过有人这么说。我不喜欢那个人。我不喜欢真实的自己，我认为所有这些结构化的存在方式或试图做对的尝试，以及有人说“我有办法”以及所有这些东西，你知道，我认为被这些东西束缚住的，特别是我们自己令人印象深刻的创造力的力量，我们直觉的美。然后另一件事是这个，我认为这是早期的荣格和一些舒尔茨（Schultes）等人所说的，美和感官的审美价值，
like congruence with beauty. Like, I don't think there's any objective way of measuring what feels congruent right good and beautiful so that's the architecture we read a lot about architecture and I've talked to a couple I'm supposed to be on the Australian Institute of Architecture's podcast a little bit later on but that's one of the things is it's like is it's an archetypal thing and not a lot of people apply Jung's theories visually I mean some artists sort of did that in the 70s and he didn't he generally did not like that art
就像与美的一致性。我不认为有什么客观的方法来衡量什么感觉是一致的、好的和美丽的，所以这就是建筑，我们读了很多关于建筑的书，我和几个建筑师谈过，我应该在澳大利亚建筑师协会的播客上，稍后一点，但这是其中之一，它是一个原型的东西，没有多少人从视觉上应用荣格的理论，我的意思是，一些艺术家在70年代确实那样做了，而他通常不喜欢那种艺术
because he thought there was supposed to be a descent and then a return. You weren't just supposed to be enamored with the unconscious and become a psychonaut. You were supposed to dissolve your ego and then come back and learn something from it and have been transformed, but also go back to being how you were.
因为他认为应该有一个下降，然后是一个回归。你不仅仅是被无意识所迷住并成为一个心理航行者。你应该溶解你的自我，然后回来，从中学习一些东西，并被转化，但也回到你原来的样子。
You know, a bit of a version of that. A hero's journey piece. But yeah, architecture is getting in touch, or filmmaking, you know, so many of those things. I mean, that's what you're saying is it's finding the beautiful isn't just, I came up with it. It's almost like, you know, intuition is like a radio wave that you tune into and channel this thing or you don't. I mean, and you can say that you could use spiritual language about that, or you could use secular language of just this kind of deep genetic programming that we're getting in touch with, but only you can run your experiment to the end
你知道，那的一个版本。英雄之旅的一部分。但是是的，建筑正在接触，或者电影制作，你知道，很多这样的事情。我的意思是，这就是你所说的，找到美不仅仅是，我想出来的。这几乎就像，你知道，直觉就像一个你调入并引导这个东西的无线电波，或者你不调入。我的意思是，你可以说你可以使用关于它的精神语言，或者你可以使用这种我们正在接触的深层遗传编程的世俗语言，但只有你能把你的实验运行到底
you know your choice is do you do that or do you fail to or do you ignore it yeah and that's again that call to adventure i like that kind of languaging around this thing and i and i think um there's a beautiful book um by um piero ferrucci i guess uh is his name and he's a psychosynthesis right and he has that i'm not and he's a psychosynthesis, right? What is that? I'm not familiar with that. Psychosynthesis? Yeah, so psychosynthesis was near the end time of Freud's process. Asagioli was a psychoanalyst, and he worked closely with Jung as well down in Italy, and he created a beautiful, beautiful model.
你知道你的选择是，你这样做，还是你失败了，还是你忽略了它。是的，这就是那种对冒险的召唤，我喜欢围绕这件事的语言，而且我认为，嗯，有一本美丽的关于皮耶罗·费鲁奇（Piero Ferrucci）的书，我想是他的名字，他是心理综合（Psychosynthesis），对吧，他有那个，我不是，他是心理综合，对吧？那是什么？我不熟悉那个。心理综合？是的，所以心理综合是在弗洛伊德过程的末期。阿萨吉奥利（Asagioli）是一位精神分析学家，他也曾在意大利与荣格密切合作，他创造了一个美丽、美丽的模型。
He was informed by theosophy which is a really cool amalgam of a lot of different spiritual concepts Latsky and these types of folks brought all that in and and a lot of those flying around Vienna around that oh yeah yeah during that time period right there's a lot of this Freud is kind of more of an inevitability than we give him credit for me there's other people or they're not giving credit more than we think we give him too much credit you know it's kind of more of an inevitability than we give him credit for i mean there's other people or they're not giving credit for than we i think we give him too much credit you know it's kind of like columbus like you have enough ships going around there somebody's gonna bump into it and realize you can't sell to india if his ship sinks somebody else does it when you look at what's
他受到神智学（Theosophy）的影响，这是一种非常酷的许多不同精神概念的融合，拉茨基（Blavatsky）和这些类型的人带来了所有这些，而且很多这些在那个时期在维也纳飞来飞去，哦是的，在那段时间里，对吧，有很多这种弗洛伊德更像是一种必然性，而不是我们给他的功劳，我的意思是，还有其他人，或者他们没有给功劳，比我们认为的更多，我们给他的功劳太多了，你知道，这有点像哥伦布，你有足够的船只在那里航行，有人会撞上它并意识到你不能航行到印度，如果他的船沉了，别人会做。当你看看
going on in vienna with like clamps everybody you know like people were going to apply this idea that maybe we are not only what we think maybe there's forces beneath the surface to medicine to psychology and they probably would have done it a little bit better than freud you know the random guy you know right and unfortunately like he had to create a modality that he could sell to a community which believed in the world in a certain kind of way, you know? Some of the earlier ideas and even the archetypical imagery that comes in, this Thanatos and Eros and... He puts the Thanatos back, you know? Yeah, like this existential requirement of this death thing, right? And then like even libidinal energy, I love that.
维也纳正在发生什么，像克莱姆特（Klimt）每个人，你知道，人们将应用这个想法，也许我们不仅仅是我们所想的，也许表面之下有力量，对医学，对心理学，他们可能会比弗洛伊德做得更好一点，你知道，那个随机的人，你知道，对吧，不幸的是，他必须创造一种他可以卖给一个以某种方式相信世界的社区的模式，你知道？一些早期的想法，甚至进来的原型意象，这个塔纳托斯（Thanatos）和厄洛斯（Eros）以及……他把塔纳托斯放回去了，你知道？是的，就像这个死亡事物的存在要求，对吧？然后像力比多能量，我喜欢那个。
Whether it goes into wilhelm reich and talking about the embodied memory system how the unconscious is the body um or or otherwise i think that there's a lot of really neat stuff there and then of course you can see a lot of this cultural overlay and you know and then then we had all this beautiful stuff pre that time even like mentalism and these different kinds of like hypnotic type concepts that used a lot of like alchemical concept and um ways of defining the world right the world is mind uh in using like the emerald tablet and these different theorems of like alchemical transformation right so um yeah i think it really set a really cool space and gave words and language to it to start playing around with
无论它进入威廉·赖希（Wilhelm Reich）并谈论具身记忆系统，无意识就是身体，还是其他，我认为那里有很多非常整洁的东西，当然你可以看到很多这种文化叠加，你知道，然后我们在那之前有所有这些美丽的东西，甚至像唯心论和这些不同种类的催眠类型概念，它们使用了许多炼金术概念和定义世界的方式，对吧，世界是心灵，使用像翡翠石板（Emerald Tablet）和这些不同的炼金术转化定理，对吧，所以嗯，是的，我认为它确实创造了一个非常酷的空间，并给了它词汇和语言来开始玩弄
it and i love that people dissented explicitly i think that that i think if anything that is what mental health is about it's like you've created a construct and i love that you've done that thank you so much for putting words out there i disagree on some of these levels and that's important because if we all collude, we, we definitely uphold the delusion. Yeah. Like, and I mean, I think one of my things has always been like,
它，我喜欢人们明确地表示异议，我认为如果有什么的话，这就是心理健康的目的，就像你创造了一个结构，我喜欢你这样做，非常感谢你把话语放出来，我在某些层面上不同意，这很重要，因为如果我们都勾结，我们，我们肯定会维持这种错觉。是的。就像，我的意思是，我认为我的事情之一一直是
I don't want to just get trained in any kind of therapy and then be the expert. I want to be in that kind of therapy as a patient before I do it with another patient. Cause there's the awe of learning and then there's the aha of feeling. And I'm, so I'm a huge advocate. I mean,
我不想只是接受任何类型的治疗培训，然后成为专家。我想在与另一个病人做之前，作为病人参与那种治疗。因为有学习的敬畏，也有感受的顿悟。而且我，所以我是一个巨大的倡导者。我的意思是，
sometimes people are kind of sheepish and they're like well i've come here for a while and you know it's like yeah you don't need therapy anymore you're fine like if you're unsettled something come back but like you should go try something else you know you've probably heard my perspective you've heard the way that i think and like you've gotten you've internalized what you need to internalize you've filtered out what you don't and like somebody else is going to tell you something different you know and that is going to be useful too so i mean union analysis was a totally different experience for me than cbt um was totally different experience um and kind of
有时人们有点害羞，他们说“嗯，我来这里有一段时间了”，你知道，就像“是的，你不再需要治疗了，你很好，如果有什么不安，回来，但你应该去尝试别的东西”，你知道，你可能听过我的观点，你听过我的思考方式，而且你已经内化了你需要内化的东西，你过滤掉了你不需要的东西，而且别人会告诉你不同的东西，你知道，那也会很有用。所以我的意思是，荣格分析对我来说是一种与CBT完全不同的体验，是完全不同的体验，而且有点
more psychodynamic but you you you learn that language and it's why i can wear the hat now you know if you just try and learn all of it intellectually and then you're like oh i read all the books that's why you're you like don't know how to apply it and you end up just picking the one you like the most you know and only doing that it's because you haven't really been in it as a patient enough to know how to do it as a provider i think i agree with that i think i've struggled with that too because again there's this price wall that's constructed in order to access certain types of approaches right like unfortunately if I label it with something, I can charge you another $50, right?
更心理动力学，但你学习那种语言，这就是为什么我现在可以戴上那顶帽子，你知道，如果你只是试图在智力上学习所有这些，然后你说“哦，我读了所有的书”，这就是为什么你不知道如何应用它，你最终只是选择了你最喜欢的一个，你知道，只做那个，这是因为你没有作为病人足够深入地参与其中，不知道如何作为提供者来做。我想我同意这一点，我想我也为此挣扎过，因为同样，为了访问某些类型的途径，存在着这种价格墙，对吧，就像不幸的是，如果我给它贴上标签，我可以再向你收取50美元，对吧？
Yeah. Yeah. And that's when you're saying that people are like coming up with these new models and then changing the name and not giving credit half the time. It's the person that they're, it's the Institute's fault that is charging you $200 to have this on your website. Cause we copyrighted a phrase. Right. Well, anded a phrase. Right. Well, and that makes sense.
是的。是的。这就是你说人们想出这些新模型，然后改名，有一半时间不给功劳的时候。这是他们，是研究所的错，向你收取200美元在你的网站上放这个。因为我们给一个短语注册了版权。对。好吧，而且给一个短语注册了版权。对。好吧，这说得通。
Yeah. Having to create language in order to not be like copyright. Here's to my movement therapies that are combinations of ETT and LP and BSP that we worked on and we're kind of doing with other therapists and we've tried on our spouses and like, it's interesting, but it's like, where do you go with that?
是的。为了不被版权起诉而不得不创造语言。这是我的运动疗法，是ETT、LP和BSP的组合，我们研究过，我们正在和其他治疗师一起做，我们已经在我们的配偶身上尝试过，而且，这很有趣，但就像，你带着那个去哪里？
If I call that ETT, I got to talk to Dr. Vasquez. If I call it brain spotting, I got to talk to, if I call it fusion, I got to talk to dr vasquez if i call it brain spotting i got to talk to if i call it fusion i got to talk to but like what do i want to do you know i don't really want to be the guy going to conferences and being like here's a new thing you know pretend i just don't want to but like or do you just make up a new thing and then have everybody be like oh so you just pulled this out of nowhere and it's not evidence-based at all like yeah i don't i don't know. You know, I hear that.
如果我称之为ETT，我得和瓦斯奎兹（Vasquez）博士谈谈。如果我称之为脑点疗法，我得和……如果我称之为融合，我得和瓦斯奎兹博士谈谈。如果我称之为脑点疗法，我得和……如果我称之为融合，我得和……但我想做什么，你知道，我真的不想成为那个去参加会议并说“这是一个新东西”的人，你知道，假装，我只是不想。但或者你只是编造一个新东西，然后让每个人都说“哦，所以你只是凭空捏造了这个，它根本没有循证依据”，就像是的，我不知道。你知道，我听到了。
Yeah. Like, for instance, like we have sensory motorcycle therapy, we have hack homie, we have all these really kind of nifty things, right, where people are labeling their personal approach to and oftentimes rooted in a lot of these traditional things. Right. So we have like vegetotherapy oriented, like Reikian stuff, like whether people want to buy into it or not, or like the outcome of Wilhelm Reich's life or any of those things,
是的。例如，我们有感觉运动心理疗法（Sensorimotor Psychotherapy），我们有哈克米（Hakomi），我们有所有这些非常巧妙的东西，对吧，人们正在给他们的个人方法贴上标签，而且通常植根于许多这些传统事物中。对。所以我们有像植物疗法（Vegetotherapy）导向的，像赖希（Reichian）的东西，无论人们是否想买账，或者像威廉·赖希生活的结局或任何这些事情，
like you're probably deriving some of your breath methodology, your observational awareness and phenomenology from old school body armoring. Yeah. Through bioenergetics. Well, Reich didn't do himself any favors either i mean he kind of he was trying to shoot down ufos with uh orgasm energy by the end of his life and
你可能正在从老派的身体盔甲中推导出你的一些呼吸方法、观察意识和现象学。是的。通过生物能量学。嗯，赖希自己也没帮上什么忙，我的意思是，他试图在生命结束时用性高潮能量击落不明飞行物，以及
rain clouds and things and that's yeah well no the fbi took all the equipment too which even for the time was kind of an overreaction i mean he really made some people mad or maybe they just wanted all the orgasm energy for themselves i don't know i mean what i think is funny too is like any psychotherapy lens like what you're talking about that kind of perspective when you you go so far into it and then you extrapolate it it like becomes a cosmology you know like jungian analysis is like oh wow there's archetypes so what does that mean and And Freud's, but Wilhelm Reich, you know, going nuts, kind of was somebody making a Freudian metaphysics, like a classical Freudian metaphysics and then being like, okay, well, if sexuality is the energy ever under everything, maybe sexuality is also the energy of the cosmos and atoms or respond to orgasms or you know what like yeah right so this orgone energy which is taken from the idea of the original libidinal energy libidinal energy is just life energy which is sexual or otherwise it's projection whatever that is but it lives right usually applied to
雨云和类似的东西，那是，是的，好吧，不，联邦调查局也拿走了所有的设备，即使在当时也是一种过激反应，我的意思是，他确实让一些人很生气，或者也许他们只是想把所有的性高潮能量留给自己，我不知道，我的意思是，我认为有趣的是，任何心理治疗镜头，就像你谈论的那种视角，当你深入其中，然后推断它时，它就像变成了一种宇宙学，你知道，荣格分析就像“哦哇，有原型”，所以那意味着什么？而弗洛伊德的，但威廉·赖希，你知道，发疯，有点像是一个制造弗洛伊德形而上学的人，就像一个经典的弗洛伊德形而上学，然后说，“好吧，如果性是能量，在一切之下，也许性也是宇宙的能量，原子对性高潮有反应”，或者你知道什么，就像是的，对。所以这种奥贡（Orgone）能量，取自原始力比多能量的想法，力比多能量只是生命能量，它是性的或其他，它是投射，无论那是什么，但它活着，通常应用于
the realm of sex more than other places yes he did um however the neat thing though is let's say like if we change our lens and we look at tantric traditions from Tibet or India, right? Now we have this idea of the interplay of this duality of relationship between energies of masculine and feminine when they use sexual language to describe the fundamental workings between polarities, right? And so in the alchemical marriage, right? So this idea of creating a total self using this sort of language, I was going to say the chemical, the Rosicrucian chemical marriage,
性的领域多于其他地方。是的，他确实，嗯，然而，妙处在于，让我们说，如果我们改变我们的镜头，看看来自西藏或印度的密宗传统，对吧？现在我们有了这种关于男性和女性能量之间这种二元关系相互作用的想法，当他们使用性语言来描述极性之间的基本运作时，对吧？所以，在炼金婚姻中，对吧？所以这种使用这种语言创造一个完整自我的想法，我本来想说化学的，玫瑰十字会的化学婚姻，
but I mean, even like just sex is kind of, you know, a big force and part of our humanity, but it also is just a pretty obvious metaphor when you're being metaphors, you know, even like, I mean, there's Psalms in the Bible that are talking about the love of God is the love that you're, you loving God is the same of the love of man or woman, you know, it's like, what does that mean? That's out now? Or they're like, you know, somebody invents like a clock and then they're like, Oh God is a watchmaker.
但我的意思是，甚至像性也是一种，你知道，巨大的力量，是我们人性的一部分，但它也只是一个相当明显的隐喻，当你使用隐喻时，你知道，甚至像，我的意思是，圣经中有诗篇谈论上帝的爱是你，你爱上帝和爱男人或女人是一样的，你知道，那意味着什么？现在出来了？或者他们就像，你知道，有人发明了一个时钟，然后他们说“哦，上帝是一个钟表匠”。
And then somebody invents architecture and they're like, God is an architect. And then somebody invents an AI and they're like, Oh, we're in a simulation. You know, it's just like the easiest way, you know, that's true. It's not too far removed. The metaphor that incorporates that i think though the nice thing though when we're starting the neat thing about that is when we connected these qualities like psychic qualities or libidinal qualities or whatever to the body what we what we can do at that point though is now we have some languaging to explore the
然后有人发明了建筑，他们说“上帝是一个建筑师”。然后有人发明了人工智能，他们说“哦，我们在模拟中”。你知道，这就像最简单的方法，你知道，那是真的。它离得不远。我认为那个包含它的隐喻，但我认为当我们开始时，关于那个的妙处在于，当我们把这些品质，像心理品质或力比多品质或任何东西连接到身体时，我们在那一点上能做的是，现在我们有一些语言来探索
phenomenology of my felt experience oh Ooh, that's excitement. How does excitement work? Well, I experienced it in this fashion in this way. And then now we're like, oh, how does my body produce energy, which is felt? Yeah, we need to engage with this world. And then we have all the kind of ways that we create creative adaptation to all the things. And that's another thing that I really love from sort of this memory reconsolidation type stuff. Coherence therapy is this Bruce Ecker and Lauren. It's like somebody trying to make a solution focused brief treatment of psychoanalysis. Interesting, because it's, it's, it's following the memory reconsolidation thing. So theoretically, right, and I've always loved this. And I don't, it always baffled me
我的感官体验的现象学。哦，那是兴奋。兴奋是如何运作的？嗯，我以这种方式体验它。然后现在我们就像，“哦，我的身体如何产生能量，这是感官的？”是的，我们需要与这个世界互动。然后我们有所有我们创造创造性适应所有事物的方式。这是我从这种记忆重巩固类型的东西中真正喜欢的另一件事。相干疗法（Coherence Therapy）是布鲁斯·埃克（Bruce Ecker）和劳伦（Laure）。这就像有人试图做一个心理分析的解决方案导向的简短治疗。有趣，因为它遵循了记忆重巩固的事情。所以从理论上讲，对吧，我一直很喜欢这个。而且我，它总是让我感到困惑
that a moment of explicit trauma can indelibly burn in a learned experience for life. If that's true, using kind of this polarities, duality process, it must... Well, it lets you know the brain is thinking about it in a different way, and like an almost religious or spiritual way. You know, other moments are not being re-experienced all the time but traumatic moments are so that's telling you that that's a different kind of memory right so this idea that it does this but my wondering is this right and I've always wondered this from the very beginning of every time I the first somatic oriented
一个明确的创伤时刻可以不可磨灭地烧毁一个终身的学习经验。如果那是真的，使用这种极性、二元过程，它必须……好吧，它让你知道大脑正在以不同的方式思考它，就像一种几乎宗教或精神的方式。你知道，其他时刻并没有一直被重新体验，但创伤时刻是，所以这告诉你那是一种不同类型的记忆，对吧？所以这个想法它这样做，但我的疑问是这个，对吧？我从我第一次，每一次我，第一个躯体导向的
therapy I think it was sensory yeah uh yeah anyway peter levine i was looking at peter he's working i was like oh this is curious is that like if a memory experiencing yeah not experiencing so if a memory can be created so powerfully in a moment it should be able to be uncreated in a moment right just making contact with the somatic memory in a way that is not retraumatizing you know in and it always like it always kind of like tickled my mind to to think that because if it can be created it should be and be able to be uncreated in such in that kind of way now we've talked about not wanting to retraumatize people and kind of titrating those experiences which which I understand however things you can't do.
治疗，我想是感觉，是的，嗯，是的，无论如何，彼得·莱文，我在看彼得，他在工作，我当时想“哦，这很有趣”，就是如果一个记忆体验，是的，不是体验，所以如果一个记忆可以在一个时刻被如此有力地创造出来，它应该能够在瞬间被取消创造，对吧？只是以一种不让你再次受创伤的方式接触躯体记忆，你知道，而且它总是，它总是有点触动我的心，去思考那个，因为如果它可以被创造，它应该能够以那种方式被取消创造。现在我们已经谈到了不想让人们再次受创伤，以及滴定那些体验，我理解，然而，你不能做的事情。
It's why you have to be able to take appropriate risks at a certain point. But there's not always a way to eat some of those memories in this bite-sized way that some of the models are designed to do. And I think you're right. In my experience working with people, and in my own kind of self-process as I go through that, there are some memories that must be experienced as a gestalt like the whole experience must be digested in the moment well brain spotting does that you know like if you if you have somebody
这就是为什么你必须能够在某个点上承担适当的风险。但并不总是有办法以某些模型设计的那种一口大小的方式来吃掉那些记忆。而且我认为你是对的。在我与人工作的经验中，以及在我自己经历那个过程的自我过程中，有些记忆必须作为格式塔（Gestalt）来体验，就像整个体验必须在当下被消化。嗯，脑点疗法做到了这一点，你知道，如果你有某人
who's pushing enough to take you all the way and I mean I've said you know I'm kind of frustrated everyone that I've ever talked to that has had a bad experience with brain spotting the provider didn't look at the people at all they didn't really map the trauma at all they were just like what do you feel here what do you feel like what do you feel here what do you feel here what do you feel here what do you feel here and the person was like nothing nothing um but like it pulled everything up at once which is kind of spiritually profound and interesting to have this two three day process where you're re-experiencing all these things mastering them and at the end you know memory comes back or you kind of realize what it was you were processing
谁在推动你，让你能够彻底走出来？我是说，我曾说过，我感到有些沮丧，因为我交谈过的每一个在 Brainspotting（脑点定位疗法）中有过糟糕体验的人，他们的治疗师根本没有观察他们，也没有真正地梳理创伤。治疗师只是不断地问：“你这里有什么感觉？你那里有什么感觉？你这里有什么感觉？”而当事人则回答：“没什么，没什么。”但这种方式却一下子把所有东西都勾了出来。这在精神层面上是非常深刻且有趣的，经历这样一个两三天的过程，重新体验所有这些事物并掌握它们，最后记忆恢复，或者你意识到自己到底在处理什么。
either yourself or working with therapists you know ett um which is you know a newer thing that yeah using the lighting yeah like it can bring up incredibly specific parts surgically you know and i loved brain spotting i still love it so it's not like you know but you know it's it's not appropriate for everything i don't think any one thing is. And it's wild. Like with ETT, there was like one of the eye movements, we had the color frequency and the person said, can you do something with like acid reflux? And I was like, well, I mean, that's not really how it works.
无论是你自己处理，还是与治疗师合作，比如 ETT（情感转化疗法），这是一种较新的事物，通过光线，它确实能极其精准地、像手术一样地引出某些部分。我喜欢 Brainspotting，现在依然喜欢，所以并不是说它不好，但它并不适用于所有情况，我认为没有任何一种方法是万能的。这太疯狂了。比如在 ETT 中，有一次眼球运动，我们使用了颜色频率，那个人问：“你能处理像胃酸倒流这样的问题吗？”我说：“嗯，这不是它的工作原理。”
But I got, you know, what was supposed to be for kind of throat, lungs, breathing, like top neck, that area, which is kind of a blue-green color, a certain flicker flicker rate whatever and she was looking at it and then immediately started remembering when she was eating as a kid and she was shamed and then she her whole stomach kind of shutting down and then this whole thing just came up but it wasn't this whole memory about your whole relationship with this child like everything it was this incredible around that one somatic emotional thing in this specific way yep yeah and I think that's speaking to this kind of memory reconsolidation thing that's that's what that also looks like right it's like every single moment that has created a pattern it has that
但我得到了原本应该是针对喉咙、肺部、呼吸、颈部上方那个区域的频率，那是一种蓝绿色，有特定的闪烁频率。她看着它，然后立刻开始回忆起小时候吃饭时被羞辱的情景，接着她的整个胃部似乎都关闭了，然后整件事就浮现出来了。但这不仅仅是关于你与这个孩子之间关系的记忆，而是围绕着那个特定的躯体情感问题，以这种特定的方式呈现。是的，我认为这正是在谈论那种“记忆重组”的过程，这看起来就是那样，对吧？就像每一个创造了某种模式的瞬间，都有它……
creative adaption started because of a reason, right? So it's like, and if we attend to that, whether again, we're focusing on a feeling, whether we're looking at a space in a visual field, whether we're moving our eyes to inhibit our amygdalas, whether we're stomping our feet, whether we're psycho, whether we're dancing, whether we're doing like, you know, any of the modalities that exist that are human modalities of expression, right? Whatever we track and whatever we stay with, if we were to stay with it enough and give language to it,
创造性的适应是有原因的，对吧？所以，如果我们关注这一点，无论是再次专注于某种感觉，还是观察视觉场中的某个空间，无论是移动眼睛来抑制杏仁核，还是跺脚，还是跳舞，或者做任何现存的人类表达方式，对吧？无论我们追踪什么，无论我们停留在什么地方，如果我们能足够久地停留并赋予它语言，
even if we were doing some like just fill in the blank sort of word association stuff, it is likely that all those roads would lead to a story, right? And the nice thing about knowing what the story is... Sometimes our body remembers it in a way that are the front of our brain can't, which is where a bunch of those modalities get stuck. I mean, if you're drugged or pass out during an experience, it can be traumatizing, but the memory is not written, right. It's like a corrupted file on the hard drive where, you know, you,
即使我们只是在做一些填空式的词语联想，所有这些道路很可能都会通向一个故事，对吧？知道故事是什么的好处在于……有时我们的身体以一种大脑前额无法记忆的方式记住了它，而这正是许多疗法陷入困境的地方。我的意思是，如果你在经历过程中被下药或昏迷，那可能会造成创伤，但记忆并没有被写入，对吧？就像硬盘上损坏的文件，你知道，你……
maybe you're all you're going to get is the body's response to it. And, and that, and that's what you have to go through and process it. But you're never going to be able to do this stuff because you didn't see it. You didn't perceive it. You know, maybe if you're very young, the damage is written in a different way. Kids don't make narrative memory until kind of three or four in a cognitive
也许你唯一能得到的就是身体对它的反应。而这正是你必须经历和处理的部分。但你永远无法做到这一点，因为你没有看到它。你没有感知到它。你知道，也许如果你很小，伤害是以不同的方式写入的。孩子们在认知上直到三四岁才形成叙事记忆。
way. Yeah. And I think, and what I like too is like the narrative that we experienced doesn't have to be the, the experience itself, right? So consciousness accessing something in a way that my total brain can experience, which involves language components often, right? When I can conceptualize it, even if it's a theme, for
方式。是的。而且我喜欢的一点是，我们经历的叙事不一定非得是体验本身，对吧？所以意识以一种我的大脑能够体验的方式获取某些东西，这通常涉及语言成分，对吧？当我能将其概念化时，即使它只是一个主题，例如，
instance, I have to not eat because I will be hurt. Now that doesn't have to have as explicit memory, but that's a felt sense that I'm giving words to. And once I can hold that with the experience in my conscious awareness now, and then I create these moments that contradict those, those are the things that unlock those old patterns. And you're right, we can do that without eliciting that cognitive piece. However, it seems, in my experience at least, that that part is very useful for having, I guess, a total gestalt, a whole story, right? Yeah, yeah. The narrative piece is a really lovely part of me understanding myself in the world
“我必须不吃东西，否则我会受伤。”现在，这不一定需要有明确的记忆，但那是一种我正在赋予词汇的身体感受。一旦我能在现在的意识中将其与体验结合起来，然后我创造出与这些模式相矛盾的时刻，这些就是解锁旧模式的关键。你是对的，我们可以在不引出认知部分的情况下做到这一点。然而，至少在我的经验中，那部分对于获得一个完整的格式塔，一个完整的故事是非常有用的，对吧？是的，是的。叙事部分是我理解自己和世界的一个非常可爱的部分。
whereas if i do a purely um somatic exercise let's say i do a holy traffic breathing or i go through like some psychedelic thing that can be really awesome however without the right framing i think those things can also be disempowering we're attributing it to some other something instead of acknowledging that it's a us thing. Yeah. Well, I think that like, it's not that the narrative is unimportant when you don't remember the event or it's not, you know, able to be perceived. It's that you don't have like an intellectual cognitive memory there. It becomes part of a bigger narrative, you know, a bigger story and you're still linking it to that, but figuring out what happened or who or whatever. I mean, even if you do knowing it was Colonel Mustard in the green room with the rope doesn't heal, you know, re-experiencing physically and then going through
而如果我只做纯粹的躯体练习，比如我做全呼吸法，或者经历某种迷幻体验，那可能真的很棒。然而，如果没有正确的框架，我认为这些事情也可能让人感到无力，因为我们将它归因于其他东西，而不是承认这是我们自己的事情。是的。嗯，我认为，当你记不住事件或无法感知它时，叙事并非不重要。而是你没有那种理性的认知记忆。它成为了一个更大叙事的一部分，你知道，一个更大的故事，你仍然把它与那个联系起来，但要弄清楚发生了什么或谁等等。我的意思是，即使你知道是“芥末上校在绿色房间里用绳子”做的，这也不能治愈，重新体验身体上的感受，然后经历……
the crisis, having the crisis resolve and then letting my heart and my body feel safety. I love that. And I love that that pattern and i think that animals are such a brilliant um exposition of that right like we have these systems because they're designed to deal with the world and when we get to a place of completion like i'm activated i activate my parasympathetic or my sympathetic responses they engage they discharge appropriately to create the safety that i need and then i take in the environment of safety, which is a completely different thing. And then it allows my body to dissipate or discharge or complete that cycle. And the huge part, and I think in most of the somatic type work is like the, it never gets finished, right? It's
危机，让危机解决，然后让我的心和身体感受到安全。我喜欢这一点。我喜欢那种模式，我认为动物是这方面非常精彩的例证，对吧？我们拥有这些系统是因为它们旨在应对世界，当我们达到完成的状态时——比如我被激活了，我激活了我的副交感神经或交感神经反应，它们参与进来，适当地释放以创造我需要的安全感，然后我吸收了安全的环境，这完全是另一回事。然后它允许我的身体消散、释放或完成那个循环。而很大一部分，我认为在大多数躯体类工作中，就是它从未完成，对吧？它是……
the unfinished business story, right? It's like, I never got to feel like it worked and I never got to feel that it's over and I never get to feel safe. So my body's going to keep on generating. But I don't want to admit that and accept that framing because I know that it's over. I know that I shouldn't have to feel that is the, is the, the fight that you get into with the more kind of ST, you know, sensory thinking type patient. And I think that's an interesting space because, and again, you have to move that into that feeling frame, right? It's like, okay, yes, you're right.
未完成的故事，对吧？就像是，我从未感觉到它起作用，我从未感觉到它结束了，我从未感觉到安全。所以我的身体会不断地产生反应。但我不想承认并接受那个框架，因为我知道它已经结束了。我知道我不应该再有那种感觉，这是你与那种“感觉思维型”患者进行斗争的地方。我认为这是一个有趣的空间，而且同样，你必须将其转移到那个感觉框架中，对吧？就像是，好吧，是的，你是对的。
It is absolutely over. And yet here you are and your body is still exhibiting behaviors necessary for that condition to be met. So how do we create an experience now where that can be done? Right. Yeah. Yeah. And yeah. And I think that's the art of therapy, right? And it's not the, yeah, it's a, it's a very curious thing. Well, it sounds like you're doing amazing work, um, when you're practicing and where you are, I mean, you have kind of longer term career plans or what, what do plans or what do you see yourself? So I just love doing therapy
它绝对结束了。然而你还在这里，你的身体仍然表现出满足该条件所必需的行为。那么我们如何创造一种体验，让它现在能够完成呢？对。是的。是的。我认为这就是治疗的艺术，对吧？这是一种非常奇妙的事情。听起来你在实践中做得非常出色，你现在的职业规划是长期的吗？或者你对自己有什么看法？我只是喜欢做治疗，
and I love reading all these things and trying to make sense of it because I'm a human in the world trying to make sense of that. The thing that I would love to do at one point, which is something I deeply appreciate about what you're doing and there's a lot of people doing this,
我喜欢阅读所有这些东西并试图理解它，因为我是一个试图理解这个世界的人类。我非常想做的一件事，这也是我非常欣赏你正在做的事情，而且有很多人在做这件事，
is putting information out for people to have access to it without any paywalls or any kind of things like that, i think i think giving people free access to information so that they can experiment with what works for them so if i were to create a fantastical future adventure for myself right um it would be to continue to learn and use mediums along the way hopefully as i feel a little bit more like grounded and confident in my own process and just share those things with always with the condition of like this could or could not be true and please experiment with it within the appropriate
就是向人们提供信息，让他们无需任何付费墙或类似的东西就能获取。我认为给人们免费获取信息的途径，让他们可以尝试什么对自己有效，这很好。所以如果我要为自己创造一个奇幻的未来冒险，那就是继续学习并使用各种媒介，希望随着我对自己过程感到更加扎实和自信，分享这些东西，并始终附带条件：“这可能是真的，也可能不是，请在适当的条件下尝试它。”
context using the appropriate supports that you need in order to achieve those outcomes you know well i i think um i'd really love you know it wouldn't it would be something that would be down the road if i was doing it but i'd love for um like taproot to be able to host like almost like a dev psychology library that's free because there's so much stuff that's out there in the in the common domain um or that people professors are retiring or whatever and they're just likely to be like yeah you can have all of my papers and make them available. And it's stuff that you can't even get to then.
在需要适当支持的情况下，以实现这些结果。你知道，嗯，我想……我真的很想，你知道，如果我去做的话，那将是未来的事情，但我很想让像 Taproot 这样的机构能够托管一个免费的心理学图书馆，因为公共领域里有太多东西了，或者教授们正在退休，他们很可能会说：“是的，你可以拿走我所有的论文并公开它们。”而这些东西你甚至无法触及。
Like, you know, that journal was gone 12 years ago or whatever. And even if you pay $600 a month, you still can't read it. But yeah, I'd love to put together something like that. You know, our website, our collective is just kind of, we're all trying to, we think we can build something that is better together than we can individually. And you get a cost sharing and everything that goes with that. But yeah, if you're ever interested in working on something
就像，你知道，那本期刊 12 年前就没了，或者类似的情况。即使你每月支付 600 美元，你仍然读不到它。但是的，我很想把这样的东西整合在一起。你知道，我们的网站，我们的集体，我们都在尝试，我们认为我们可以一起建立比单独建立更好的东西。你可以分摊成本以及随之而来的一切。但如果你有兴趣在某些事情上合作，
that we, if we could help, like if, you know, I can give you the access to the website to, you know, kind of host or build something on the backend, like, I don't know, some kind of electronic thing, if that's ever anything you're interested in and doing Awesome. Thank you so much for taking some time to kind of explore some concepts around the therapy It's lovely to explore and have these conversations and I think It helps kind of flesh out and build some
如果我们能提供帮助，比如，我可以给你网站的访问权限，让你在后端托管或构建一些东西，比如，我不知道，某种电子化的东西，如果这是你感兴趣的话。太棒了。非常感谢你花时间探索关于治疗的一些概念。探索并进行这些对话很棒，我认为这有助于充实并建立一些……
Deeper understanding for myself. So thank you very much for taking some time with me Yeah, I mean and I've got you know, I got to pick my daughter up in just a minute deeper understanding for myself. So thank you very much for taking some time with me. Yeah. I mean, and I've got, you know, I got to pick my daughter up in just a minute, but I've got 15, 20 minutes or so. I mean, what, like, is there anything else? Cause I don't want to, you had reached out and I think initially with some questions or things you wanted to discuss, and I would like to, you know, get to all of that stuff. I don't know how much of that was included in what we already did. Yeah, I think a fair bit was. Yeah, so we have another about 15 minutes. Is that right?
对我自己更深层的理解。所以非常感谢你花时间陪我。是的，我的意思是，你知道，我得去接我女儿了，就在一分钟内。对我自己更深层的理解。所以非常感谢你花时间陪我。是的，我的意思是，你知道，我得去接我女儿了，就在一分钟内，但我还有 15 到 20 分钟左右。我的意思是，还有什么吗？因为我不想，你之前联系过我，我想最初有一些问题或你想讨论的事情，我想，你知道，处理所有这些事情。我不知道我们已经做的部分包含了多少。是的，我想相当多。是的，所以我们还有大约 15 分钟。是这样吗？
Yeah. I can try and get in touch with you later this week. November is a lot. The past three months have been just like the most wild ever. But it's calming, relatively. So some things that I wonder that I would like to bring up or explore with the time that we have left.
是的。我可以尝试在本周晚些时候联系你。十一月太忙了。过去三个月简直是最疯狂的。但相对来说，现在平静了一些。所以，我想提出或利用剩下的时间探索一些我感到好奇的事情。
Because I'm not officially trained in any of these things and also there's these paywalls to get exposure and therapy through these things, I usually wind up being the subject of my own experimentation. So I apply these things, the methods and concepts to myself as often as possible. it's using um brain spotting right and i kind of like feeling that felt sense and associating with that or it's short work or otherwise right so i definitely
因为我没有接受过这些方面的正式培训，而且获取这些治疗和接触这些东西有付费墙，所以我通常最终成为自己实验的对象。所以我尽可能多地将这些方法和概念应用到自己身上。这是使用 Brainspotting，我喜欢那种身体感受并与之关联，或者短程工作等等，所以我绝对……
understand the value of having another person i think that that fundamentally changes you can't always do it you can't always afford it or there's right to be local or what i mean sometimes the self-work is the only option for certain things right and yeah absolutely i agree with that so one thing that i was wondering about and and i did some more research and things when i first saw brain spotting said oh my goodness this looks really interesting i like this idea right and this is also before i ran into memory reasons with any kind of therapy too you know even like cognitive behavioral people like it i mean there's somebody in the training usually it's more kind of less cognitive providers and somebody who was one of the trainers and one of the things was like i'm a cognitive therapy person that does brain spotting
理解有另一个人在场的重要性。我认为这从根本上改变了你，你不能总是做到这一点，你不能总是负担得起，或者没有当地的资源，或者我的意思是，有时自我工作是某些事情的唯一选择，对吧？是的，我绝对同意这一点。所以有一件事我很好奇，当我第一次看到 Brainspotting 时，我做了一些研究，我说：“天哪，这看起来真的很有趣，我喜欢这个想法。”这还是在我接触任何疗法的记忆重组之前。你知道，即使是认知行为疗法的人也喜欢它，我的意思是，培训中通常会有一些人，通常是那种不太偏向认知的提供者，其中一位培训师说：“我是一个做 Brainspotting 的认知疗法者。”
and i was like oh wow and i was listening and she was like you know brain spotting does the thing where cognitive therapy can actually work because the body calms down and then they can learn all this stuff you know it's like oh wow that's a neat way to think about behavior you know but that's what my problem with behaviorism is that they think you can change behavior by talking about it you know most times people know what they're supposed to do they just right do that yeah right and that's that experimental needing to experience that's the experiential therapies that were in the 1960s 1970s when they were doing all this really good stuff and then we get into these ethical quandaries that have created what we have today to some degree but this is what it is that i but i really
我当时想：“哦，哇。”我听着，她说：“你知道，Brainspotting 做了认知疗法真正能起作用的事情，因为身体平静下来了，然后他们就能学习所有这些东西。”你知道，这是一种看待行为的巧妙方式。但这就是我对行为主义的问题所在，他们认为你可以通过谈论来改变行为。你知道，大多数时候人们知道他们应该做什么，他们只是……做不到。是的，对。这就是那种需要体验的实验，那是 1960 年代和 1970 年代的体验式疗法，当时他们正在做所有这些真正好的事情，然后我们陷入了这些伦理困境，在某种程度上造成了我们今天所拥有的局面。但这就是我所处的现状，但我真的……
deeply appreciate living now in that there's so much beautiful there's like a thousand waterfalls pouring into this um current you know zeitgeist right this current like space and yeah if if i want to and i'm open to it and i i can i can check my prejudices against certain conceptualizations and methods i can make a lot of really beautiful stuff that's very transformative um so one thing as i i was doing these kind of experiments right kind of like playing with that up down using the zxy accesses different kind of like checking different points and like moving between different points what i know is i can't do brain spotting on myself at all like there's different kind of like checking different points and like moving between different points. What I know is I can't do brain spotting on myself at all. Like there's inside and outside window when you get trained and outside window is where the provider is just like,
深深地感激现在的生活，因为有太多美好的东西，就像有一千条瀑布汇入这个……当前的时代精神，对吧？这个当前的空间。是的，如果我愿意，并且对此持开放态度，我可以检查我对某些概念化和方法的偏见，我可以创造出很多非常美丽且具有变革性的东西。所以，当我做这些实验时，比如玩弄那种上下移动，使用 ZXY 轴，检查不同的点，并在不同的点之间移动，我知道我根本无法对自己进行 Brainspotting。就像有内窗和外窗，当你接受培训时，外窗是治疗师只是……
and inside window is when you're trying to see what the person feels. Yeah. And for me, like, so outside window is a lot more effective in my experience. Cause a ton of my patients are so dissociated. They don't know what they feel anyway. So they're like, I don't notice anything there. And I'm like, no, just hang out a minute. You're gonna feel it. But when I do brain spotting with my therapist, I'm just like, I don't know, I think I felt something here.
而内窗是你试图观察对方感受的时候。是的。对我来说，外窗在我的经验中更有效。因为我的很多病人非常解离。他们无论如何都不知道自己的感受。所以他们说：“我没注意到那里有什么。”我说：“不，再待一会儿。你会感觉到的。”但当我与我的治疗师做 Brainspotting 时，我只是说：“我不知道，我想我在这里感觉到了什么。”
And she's like, nah, and then I'm gone. So sometimes you can, sometimes you can't. I'm particularly bad at it. So I'm wondering in your processing, so when I did this thing and I'm kind of playing around with this, and as I'm holding this space, I'm kind of like noticing my natural responses, right?
她说：“不。”然后我就断片了。所以有时你可以，有时你不能。我特别不擅长这个。所以我很好奇你的处理过程，当我做这件事并玩弄它时，当我保持这个空间时，我注意到我的自然反应，对吧？
Maybe some swallowing, maybe some like rapid blinking, maybe the eyes start to, you know, agitate. Maybe I start feeling kind of those little neurogenic tremors that we're getting from this body discharge stuff. And I love that. And it makes total sense from a biological standpoint, right? Everything starts with orienting, right? Every, every, every, everything started with with orienting right period every every every everything started with an orienting reflex that's fun that's just how it is right you and so i find this place i hold that in space right holding that and what i've noticed in my own process as i've been playing with that in certain cases i'll start there with a feeling, right? There's a felt sense. I'm experiencing that. I'm with it. And then my mind will automatically start populating that with parts. So now what I've seen
也许是一些吞咽，也许是一些快速眨眼，也许眼睛开始，你知道，烦躁。也许我开始感觉到那些来自身体释放的神经源性震颤。我喜欢这一点。从生物学角度来看，这完全说得通，对吧？一切都始于定向，对吧？每一、每一、每一、每一件事都始于定向，对吧？句号。每一、每一、每一件事都始于定向反射。这很有趣，事实就是这样，对吧？你……所以我找到了这个地方，我保持在空间里，保持那个状态。我注意到在自己的过程中，当我玩弄它时，在某些情况下，我会从一种感觉开始，对吧？有一种身体感受。我正在体验它。我与它同在。然后我的大脑会自动开始用“部分”来填充它。所以现在我所看到的……
happens is here's my finger. My finger is there. I'm attending to this. And then my finger becomes a part, right? So now I'm noticing that there's me, a self, a part there. And then it has dialogue and concept that starts playing out in my mind. and then I'm playing out in my active other parts are starting to play out there and if I hold that space my my processing right my primary modalities and otherwise that's what they like to do they create a dialogue oriented story because I'm very auditory mm-hmm and then they'll play that through to a sense of completion however that story wants to kind of close itself up mm-hmm I'm kind of curious though and that's what really drew me to this is like what if we you know because also the other piece is like if you have your
发生的是，这是我的手指。我的手指在那里。我正在关注这一点。然后我的手指变成了一个“部分”，对吧？所以现在我注意到有我，一个自我，一个部分在那里。然后它开始在我脑海中进行对话和概念化。然后我正在……活跃的其他部分开始在那里上演，如果我保持那个空间，我的处理过程，我的主要模式和其他方式，这就是他们喜欢做的，他们创造一个对话导向的故事，因为我非常听觉化。嗯哼。然后他们会将其演绎到一种完成感，无论那个故事想要如何结束自己。嗯哼。但我有点好奇，这正是真正吸引我的地方，就像如果我们……因为另一个部分是，如果你有你的……
eyes closed and you do this as well right your eyes still move if you close because that's just what we do to access information and the neuro-linguistic program folks talk about this decades and decades and decades ago yeah um but i'm kind of curious is that they didn't have the neurology though i'd like the problem is like they they don't distinguish between prefrontal and subbrain and so like that's why it doesn't work it's like the the eye movement nlp stuff is neurologically very interesting but your eye is going to drift there when you're really feeling like you could just look here and lie so saying constructed memories here audio memories there like that's not the best metaphor about how the brain works because it can do
眼睛闭着，你也这样做，对吧？你的眼睛仍然会移动，如果你闭着，因为那是我们获取信息的方式。神经语言程序学（NLP）的人几十年前就谈论过这一点。嗯，但我有点好奇，他们当时没有神经学知识。问题是，他们没有区分前额叶和大脑深层，所以这就是为什么它不起作用。就像眼球运动 NLP 的东西在神经学上非常有趣，但当你真正感觉到时，你的眼睛会漂移到那里，你可能只是看着这里并撒谎。所以说构建的记忆在这里，听觉记忆在那里，这不是关于大脑如何工作的最佳隐喻，因为它能做……
different things you know right yeah the location i think is interesting but they using and discussing the visual field and how tracking side to side from different areas of vision. Yeah, yeah. Super fascinating, I think. I'm sort of wondering, what's been your experience? You don't have to give any explicit information, but when you've worked with folks and you're doing this brain spotting type methodology, either the fixed point or you're kind of like jumping between points or tracking between things or whatever,
不同的事情，你知道，对吧？是的，位置我认为很有趣，但他们使用并讨论视觉场，以及如何从视觉的不同区域左右追踪。是的，是的。我认为超级迷人。我有点好奇，你的经验是什么？你不必提供任何明确的信息，但当你与人们合作并进行这种 Brainspotting 类型的疗法时，无论是固定点，还是你在点之间跳跃，或者追踪事物等等，
does it often have a narrative component like do people often um express to you that they're experiencing an internal story with parts um do you and there's a whole branch therapy is like fuses so well with brain spotting it's almost becoming part of the training like most of the trainers will train you in it and i'm not certified in it so i mean i've done phase one and two and then you know or consult with a lot of people that have done a lot of the different new ones because there's a lot of splinter ones now um but it sounds like what you're asking is like is there a pattern with eye movement from nlp iqs that is relevant with brain spawning or do you are you saying do people see a story when they hit the eye position i think what i think if i were to distill that it would be when people are holding
它通常有叙事成分吗？人们是否经常向你表达他们正在经历一个带有“部分”的内在故事？你……而且有一个完整的疗法分支与 Brainspotting 融合得如此之好，它几乎成为了培训的一部分。大多数培训师都会对你进行这方面的培训，我没有获得认证，所以我做过第一阶段和第二阶段，然后，你知道，或者咨询过很多做过不同新版本的人，因为现在有很多分支版本。但听起来你在问的是，NLP 眼动与 Brainspotting 是否有相关的模式？或者你是说当人们到达眼位时，他们是否看到了一个故事？我想如果我要提炼它，那将是：当人们保持……
an eye position are they accessing a awareness and part or is it a part and a part inevitably sometimes like part space therapy can get you there but when you're there with brain spotting you're so deep in a lot of the time, you're losing time. Like you don't like I dissociated for like 20 minutes when I did the training and I was expecting nothing because EMDR didn't do anything for me. I was like, well, but I saw it work for some patients. I was like, well, I'll take some of the things from this training. And it was during COVID. We were on a screen.
一个眼位时，他们是在获取一种意识和一个部分，还是一个部分和一个部分？不可避免地，有时像“部分空间疗法”可以带你到那里，但当你使用 Brainspotting 时，你很多时候陷得太深了，你会失去时间感。就像我做培训时解离了大约 20 分钟，我什么都没期待，因为 EMDR 对我没用。我说：“好吧，但我看到它对一些病人有效。”我说：“好吧，我会从这次培训中吸取一些东西。”那是在新冠期间。我们在屏幕上。
It wasn't even in person. I was like, how could my eye know how far the thing is away? And I mean, I like felt like I just needed to move my head like i was in water kind of and i was just silent and if it takes me and not everybody goes in that deeply with processing but if you do um like you usually lose time like so the person thinks the session was 10 minutes and it really is i'm like it's at the end of the hour because it took me 10 minutes to get them to go down so when you're really deep in it's more about the difference with like ett and brain spotting and emdr is like brain spotting most of the processing is not in the room you're like opening this box and throwing all this stuff from the sub brain up into the mid brain but like
甚至不是面对面。我说：“我的眼睛怎么知道那个东西有多远？”我的意思是，我感觉就像我需要移动我的头，就像我在水里一样，我只是沉默。如果它带我进入，并不是每个人都会处理得那么深，但如果你进入了，嗯……你通常会失去时间感。所以那个人认为疗程是 10 分钟，实际上是……我说是小时结束了，因为我花了 10 分钟让他们进入状态。所以当你真正深入时，更多的是关于 ETT 和 Brainspotting 与 EMDR 的区别，就像 Brainspotting，大部分处理过程不在房间里。你就像打开这个盒子，把所有这些来自大脑深层的东西扔进中脑，但……
the front of the brain hypothetically i mean don't send me an email and say i can't prove that i can't yeah you don't even know what you're thinking about for like two days like you don't know what it is and you also don't really get to pick what you hit as much right i like it because the processing is so much more predictable like with emdr very few people do this but it's still terrible when it happens and it's possible with complex trauma like sometimes somebody would come into process like a car wreck and you do it and they feel great and then they're thanking you and whatever two days later totally decompensate i just remember this thing from when i was a kid i'm totally shutting down totally whatever okay we're gonna process that and you know dad did this thing okay and then decompensate again oh but mom was watching i thought she was
大脑前额，假设是这样——别给我发邮件说我无法证明这一点，我无法证明。是的，你甚至不知道你在想什么，持续大约两天。你不知道那是什么，而且你也不能真正选择你触碰到什么，对吧？我喜欢它，因为处理过程更可预测。使用 EMDR，很少有人这样做，但当它发生时仍然很糟糕，而且对于复杂创伤来说，有时有人会进来处理，比如车祸，你做了，他们感觉很好，然后他们感谢你等等。两天后完全崩溃了。我只记得小时候的这件事，我完全关闭了，完全……无论如何，好吧，我们要处理那个。你知道，爸爸做了这件事，好吧，然后再次崩溃。哦，但妈妈在看，我以为她是……
my protector now and they can't work and you know like that decompensation just doesn't happen with brain spawning that way it's it's not that there's no decompensation. I said, it's so predictable that you can, if it either doesn't work, you didn't, that it's like you can knock the ball over the hill and it's going to roll down or you can keep knocking the ball up the hill. If you didn't get it to pop, like if you didn't go all the way through it, just nothing happens. You may feel kind of weird, but you didn't, you didn't open it.
我的保护者。现在他们无法工作，你知道，那种崩溃在 Brainspotting 中不会那样发生。并不是说没有崩溃。我说，它是如此可预测，以至于你可以……如果它不起作用，你没有……就像你可以把球推过山坡，它会滚下去，或者你可以一直把球推上山坡。如果你没有让它“弹出”，如果你没有一直走到底，什么都不会发生。你可能会觉得有点奇怪，但你没有……你没有打开它。
If you open it, then they go all the way through this thing for usually two three days you know if you're obsessive if you're compulsively trying to figure out what it is if you're smoking a lot of marijuana if you're drinking a lot of alcohol if you're doing anything obsessively you're going to slow processing down you know but it will still work it's just don't do that because like it will make the bad part last longer um but like your dreams are very weird usually they're kind of like letting you know what you're chewing on they're kind of archetypal they're just weird they're not normal dreams a lot of times there's very photo real slick moments in it you know that happened for me it's happened for a lot of my patients with ett and brain spawning or with ett
如果你打开了它，那么他们通常会经历两三天。你知道，如果你强迫性地试图弄清楚那是什么，如果你吸食大量大麻，如果你喝大量酒精，如果你强迫性地做任何事情，你就会减慢处理过程。你知道，但它仍然会起作用，只是别那样做，因为这会让糟糕的部分持续更久。嗯，但你的梦通常非常奇怪，它们有点像是在让你知道你在咀嚼什么。它们有点原型化，它们只是奇怪，它们不是正常的梦。很多时候里面有非常逼真的瞬间，你知道，这发生在我身上，也发生在我很多使用 ETT 和 Brainspotting 的病人身上。或者使用 ETT……
the processing is like five six hours and it's very specific you don't have that huge thing does that kind of answer your question so saying is it activating a part or not like you can use parts work to be like okay like i'll use it to be like all right now map that defensive part of you like what does your spine want to do and the person's like i don't know you're like no really listen like you're feeling this like they're big you want to curl up into a ball well i kind of want to bend okay are you wanting to curl up into a ball like you're protecting yourself are you covering something up like you're you don't want to be seen you want to be invisible do you want to just train spotting like flip back into the carpet and disappear in that way
处理过程大约是五六个小时，而且非常具体，你不会有那种巨大的东西。这能回答你的问题吗？所以说它是激活了一个部分还是没有？你可以使用“部分工作”来像这样：“好吧，我会用它来……好吧，现在映射你那个防御性的部分。你的脊椎想做什么？”那个人说：“我不知道。”你说：“不，真的，听着……你感觉到了这个……他们很大，你想蜷缩成一个球吗？嗯，我有点想弯曲。好吧，你是想蜷缩成一个球，就像你在保护自己吗？你在掩盖什么吗？就像你……你不想被看见，你想隐形吗？你想只是像 Brainspotting 一样翻回地毯里并以那种方式消失吗？”
do you are you tense like you're bracing for impact like you're a foot you're going to be like that's all interesting information getting them to go into the experience that would be parts based and mapping this part and what it somatically is and what it ideologically, what does the world around you feel like? If you feel small, that means everything around you must be bigger. Do I look bigger? Do I look intimidating? You know, do you feel smaller than the room? Weight, do you feel lighter than the room, heavier than the room? You feel, it could be green. You could feel green. It doesn't have to make sense. It could, you could feel VCR static. You know,
你……你紧张吗？就像你在为冲击做准备，就像你是一只脚，你会像……那都是有趣的信息。让他们进入那种体验，那将是基于部分的，并映射这个部分，它在躯体上是什么，以及它在意识形态上是什么，你周围的世界感觉如何？如果你感觉很小，那意味着你周围的一切一定更大。我看起来更大吗？我看起来令人生畏吗？你知道，你感觉比房间小吗？重量，你感觉比房间轻，比房间重吗？你感觉……它可能是绿色的。你可能感觉是绿色的。它不需要有意义。它可能……你可能感觉到录像带的静电。你知道，
what, what is that? And, and that, then that lets the eye open and you go in, you know, but when you're going in, you're never like,
那是什么？然后，那让眼睛睁开，你进入了，你知道，但当你进入时，你从来不会像……
I'm fighting the inner critic. This is what I have to, like, it's a pretty deep brain thing. Like generally there's not much talking. And yeah, I think that that's useful to kind of hear. I think so in different forms of parts
“我正在与内在批评者斗争。”这是我必须……就像，这是一个相当深层的大脑活动。通常没有太多谈话。是的，我认为听到这些很有用。我想在不同形式的“部分”……
work right so you and this is kind of it covers a lot of different ones it's just a strategy you're working with somebody and they're accessing these things they okay yeah cool if this were to be in the room here where would it be now in inherently they do gaze spotting right so they know they will naturally so the question I wonder and this is a philosophical question as it isn't there's no neurobiology to define it right i wonder if whenever we do that we are looking at something that's inside of us that we projected so if if on a on a creative construct level we're always looking at something right because you can um
工作中，对吧？所以你……这涵盖了很多不同的类型，这只是一种策略。你正在与某人合作，他们正在获取这些东西，他们……好吧，是的，酷。如果这要出现在房间里，它现在会在哪里？本质上，他们会进行“凝视定位”，所以他们知道，他们会自然地……所以我好奇的问题是，这是一个哲学问题，因为它不是……没有神经生物学来定义它，对吧？我想知道，每当我们这样做时，我们是否在看某种我们投射出来的内在东西。所以如果……在创造性构建层面上，我们总是看着某种东西，对吧？因为你可以……
another thing you're saying is that how the brain works or is that where you're looking to a specific experience where you're i'm wondering if that's just a normal function of how the brain does this right so if i if i find a space right and we have the other examples working with kids you put a little fluffy paper on of it or and I mean traditional sand tray therapy right there I gazing down and they're fixating on certain areas these are just naturally occurring processes that pre-existent because they're human right you you're working with somebody then they naturally fixate on a specific location and then they'll just start.
另一件事你说的是大脑如何工作，还是你指的是你正在寻找一个特定的体验，你……我好奇这是否只是大脑如何做到这一点的一个正常功能，对吧？所以如果我……如果我找到一个空间，对吧？我们有其他与孩子合作的例子，你放一张小绒纸在上面，或者……我的意思是传统的沙盘疗法，在那里他们向下凝视，他们固定在某些区域。这些只是自然发生的过程，因为他们是人类，对吧？你……你正在与某人合作，然后他们自然地固定在一个特定的位置，然后他们就会开始。
However. Yeah. What is the thousand yard stare in PTSD? It's somebody looking at something that isn't there because their eyes memory from the past, you know? Yeah. I mean, if I'm understanding your question,
然而。是的。PTSD 中的“千码凝视”是什么？那是某人看着不存在的东西，因为他们的眼睛……来自过去的记忆，你知道？是的。我的意思是，如果我理解你的问题，
like, I think it's a little bit of both. I mean, what David Grand would say, the brain spotting guy is that like, you can't know anything about how the brain works. So that's making an assumption and you can't do that. So just get out of the way and let the patient's experience take you
就像，我认为两者都有。我的意思是，David Grand，那个 Brainspotting 的人会说，你不可能知道大脑是如何工作的。所以那是做出了假设，你不能那样做。所以只要让开，让病人的体验带你去……
somewhere, which is probably, you know, right. You know, as a researcher, in my experience, if you don't have some kind of conceptualization,
某个地方，这可能是，你知道，对的。你知道，作为一名研究人员，在我的经验中，如果你没有某种概念化，
at least for me, like of helping them understand what's happening, a lot of people aren't going to go anywhere. Like there's no buy-in. And so you can't really even get them to the place where they feel it and kind of understand that it's working um but i think like there are times where somebody specifically looked there during a traumatic event and that's they remember their buddy got blowed up or they remember whatever but when they're looking at that spot that memory the visual tends to like come back in the room and they're like
至少对我来说，比如帮助他们理解正在发生的事情，很多人是不会去任何地方的。就像没有买账。所以你甚至不能让他们到达他们感觉到它并理解它正在起作用的地方。嗯，但我认为……有些时候，某人在创伤事件中专门看向那里，那就是他们记得他们的伙伴被炸飞了，或者他们记得任何事情。但当他们看着那个点时，那个记忆，视觉往往会回到房间里，他们就像……
thinking about it and then there's other things that i think are more about brain function like resource spots tend to be down here you know they tend to be lower and you can and there i've heard people speculate about like well maybe that's where kids look under their desk to self-soothe or something like that but for me like it's like going back i mean some of what we do now is like a fusion of the ett the brain spotting the nlp iqs that we've been looking at how that works because if i put the glasses on you and i cover up you know your left your right eye so that everything's going through the right side of the brain because the left eye is connecting the right side of the brain why do 95 of people have a resource spot right here that immediately if you pull all the anxiety off and you kind of it's not processing anything it's
想着它，然后还有其他我认为更多是关于大脑功能的事情。比如资源点往往在这里下方，你知道，它们往往更低。你可以……我听说人们推测，比如，好吧，也许那是孩子们在桌子底下看以自我安抚的地方，或者类似的东西。但对我来说，就像回到过去……我的意思是，我们现在做的一些事情是 ETT、Brainspotting、NLP IQs 的融合，我们一直在研究它是如何工作的。因为如果我给你戴上眼镜，我遮住你的左眼，你的右眼，这样一切都通过大脑的右侧，因为左眼连接着大脑的右侧，为什么 95% 的人在这里有一个资源点，如果我立刻把所有的焦虑都拉走，你……它没有处理任何东西，它……
not an activation spot, but they're processing it, they're, they're feeling calmer. And then you go into processing, it works better. You know, like, I don't think 98% of people saw something right here as a kid. I think that more as a brain function thing. So, I mean, that's of course, incredibly speculative, but does that make sense that I think it's both? But I think that the memories that are related to where you were looking during an event. That was true for me, too. I remember, like, looking at a spot and having memories come back from childhood and then being like, oh, brain spawning works. That's cool. When I was just reading the book and trying to do it to myself. And then that's like the least part of the process. Like, that very deep in at all that's not how the process works um does that answer you i don't i feel like i'm talking a lot and i don't know if i'm answering what you're asking yeah no i think that that works i think part of mine is uh speculative right and so i like how you kind of reiterated like we can't fundamentally know what the brain does it is useful though and then it sounds like in your
不是一个激活点，但他们正在处理它，他们……他们感觉更平静了。然后你进入处理过程，它效果更好。你知道，我不认为 98% 的人在小时候在这里看到了什么。我认为那更多是关于大脑功能的事情。所以，我的意思是，这当然是极其推测性的，但这是否说得通，我认为两者都有？但我认为与你在事件发生时看向哪里有关的记忆。这对我来说也是真的。我记得，比如，看着一个点，让童年的记忆回来，然后觉得，哦，Brainspotting 有效。这很酷。当我只是在读那本书并试图对自己做这件事时。然后那只是过程的一小部分。就像，那非常深入，那根本不是过程的工作方式。嗯，这能回答你吗？我感觉我说了太多，我不知道我是否回答了你在问什么。是的，不，我想那行得通。我想我的一部分是……推测性的，对吧？所以我喜欢你如何重申……我们无法从根本上知道大脑做什么。这很有用，听起来在你的……
own research what you're exploring is how the eyes which are an external part what the brain does. It is useful though. And then it sounds like in your own research, what you're exploring is how the eyes, which are an external part of the brain, how they affect the way that the brain works and processes things. And sometimes it's, it's almost as if there's just a mechanical framework that if it's held generates a certain kind of reflexive response. Well, it's like if you are building a held generates a certain kind of reflexive response well it's like if you are building a computer i'm kind of dating myself everything system on a chip now but like when you build a computer the stuff that has to talk immediately has to be right next to each other like the the cpu has ram on the chip and then the ram has to be right next to it and the hard drive can be farther away because the latency is less and everything else is filtered through
自己的研究中，你正在探索眼睛（作为大脑的一个外部部分）如何影响大脑工作和处理事物的方式。有时，这几乎就像有一个机械框架，如果保持住，就会产生某种反射性反应。嗯，就像如果你正在构建一个……产生某种反射性反应。嗯，就像如果你正在构建一个计算机，我有点暴露年龄了，现在一切都是片上系统，但当你构建计算机时，必须立即通信的东西必须彼此非常靠近，比如 CPU 在芯片上有 RAM，然后 RAM 必须紧挨着它，硬盘可以远一点，因为延迟更小，其他一切都经过过滤……
kind of like mid and front brain that's a sense smell goes pretty deep into memory but the visual optic nerve directly through to the brainstem because you have to see something and jump when you're a lizard i mean that's the oldest part of the brain like and you can't think about it you don't need to pontificate and like you just have to move so it's like with brain spotting somebody's moving before they know why i mean for me i felt like i was moving my back of my arm but i wasn't choosing to like i didn't know why that was happening um and it was confusing and um like so i'm kind of losing my train of thought of what we were talking about um but like the yeah anyway i think vision and the pupil is giving you the best fastest indicator of what's happening in a client's experience even if they're not aware like with
就像中脑和前脑一样，嗅觉与记忆的联系非常深，但视觉视神经是直接通向脑干的，因为当你还是蜥蜴的时候，你必须看到东西并做出跳跃反应，我的意思是那是大脑最古老的部分，你不需要思考，不需要长篇大论，你只需要行动。所以就像脑点法（Brainspotting）一样，人在知道原因之前就已经在移动了。对我来说，我感觉我在移动我的后臂，但我并不是主动选择的，我不知道为什么会发生这种情况，这很令人困惑。我有点忘了我们刚才在谈论什么，但无论如何，我认为视觉和瞳孔能为你提供关于客户体验最快、最好的指标，即使他们自己并没有意识到。
ett people dissociate on certain colors when that color goes black and they're like they know it's yellow but they can't see it yeah that's immediately detecting dissociation whereas normally i'm having to look or do you look spacey what's your posture doing are you having trouble trying to think of thought oh every time i bring up mom this happens it would take you know multiple sessions to detect association sometimes immediately there you go like with the pupil you're able to see immediately what the brain is doing right if parasympathetic is you know active or if sympathetic is active you know when your pupil is just super wide under the same lighting for no reason every time you're in one location something's there right yeah and i think that's like one of the most observable
有些人会在特定颜色上产生解离，当那种颜色变黑时，他们知道那是黄色，但他们看不见。是的，这能立即检测到解离，而通常我必须观察，或者问你看起来是否走神了？你的姿势怎么样？你在思考时是否有困难？哦，每次我提到妈妈时都会发生这种情况。这有时需要多次会话才能检测到解离，而通过瞳孔，你可以立即看到大脑正在做什么，副交感神经是否活跃，或者交感神经是否活跃。你知道，当你的瞳孔在同样的灯光下无缘无故地变得超级大时，每次你在某个位置时，肯定有什么东西在那里。是的，我认为这是最可观察到的指标之一。
if you attend to it right it's very clear and very descriptive um versus a felt sense of a micro tremor in the iliopsoas of a human, right? Unless they have like a well-developed felt sense and ability to track that, it's very hard to like touch into the body oriented things upfront like that. So I think, yeah, absolutely. Yeah. I think for myself, it's definitely one that I'm kind of curious in exploring a little bit more, the brain spotting generally. And then by my own self, for my own benefit, there's theorizing about what that looks like, how that works and how to that. Organically, right, I know it sounds like you're asking how you would integrate brain spawning with other things you're doing. Is that kind of like speak to that is like I really love the inherent flow of how the thing how we process and how we move and are as beings so I like when things naturally fall into a method right it's like oh and now we're here and this eye is over here now let's do this and these things i really struggle to some degree applying uh top down like directive approaches to other people
如果你关注它，它非常清晰且具有描述性，这与人类髂腰肌的微震颤的感受不同。除非他们有非常发达的感受能力和追踪能力，否则很难直接触及身体层面的东西。所以我认为，绝对是这样。对于我自己来说，我确实对探索脑点法更感兴趣。对于我自己的利益，我正在理论化它看起来是什么样子，它是如何工作的，以及如何有机地实现它。我知道这听起来像是在问你如何将脑点法与你正在做的其他事情整合。我想说的是，我真的很喜欢我们处理事物、移动以及作为生命体存在的那种内在流动性，所以我喜欢事物自然地融入一种方法，比如‘哦，现在我们在这里，眼睛在这里，现在让我们做这个’。在某种程度上，我确实很难对其他人应用自上而下的指令式方法。
because my ultimate belief is about therapy generally right it's like i don't want to have this i you i would love for you to be able to learn how you work in such a way that you can make this happen on your own if needed. You're wondering how to give people a lens to make this something that you could do individually? Yeah, I think that that's the ultimate thing and whatever languaging that works with or whatever pre preamble or psychoeducation ultimately it's this is naturally you, you've been taught not to, how do I give you, how do I help or provide the service where you can learn to heal yourself in
因为我关于治疗的终极信念是，我不希望你依赖我，我希望你能学会如何以一种方式运作，这样如果需要的话，你可以自己实现这一点。你是在想如何给人们一个视角，让他们能独立做到这一点吗？是的，我认为这是最终目标，无论使用什么语言，无论什么前言或心理教育，最终这都是你天生的一部分，你只是被教导不要这样做。我该如何帮助你或提供服务，让你学会如何自我疗愈？
the way that you're designed to do that without all cultural, you know, inhibitions or requiring a therapist, even though I can definitely speak to and honor the fact that it can process much quicker and much more efficiently when we have that central vagal connection and sense of safety. Well, I think that like, there's a ton of people who have tried to write therapy as a book, you know, write a modality into there's a guy who did that with Adlerian therapy. It's something self. There's a guy that did that with IFS that brought a ton of people to IFS because it's basically how you do IFS to yourself. And, and, and those work for the people who they work for who needs that modality but the real the benefit of having a therapist in the room with you is that i can switch between this like
以你被设计的方式去做，而不受所有文化抑制的影响，也不需要治疗师，尽管我绝对可以承认并尊重这样一个事实：当我们有那种中央迷走神经连接和安全感时，处理过程会更快、更有效。嗯，我认为有很多人试图把治疗写成一本书，把一种模式写进去。有一个人对阿德勒疗法做了这件事，还有人对IFS（内在家庭系统疗法）做了这件事，这把很多人带到了IFS，因为它基本上就是你如何对自己进行IFS。对于那些需要这种模式的人来说，这些书确实有效，但有治疗师在房间里的真正好处是，我可以切换模式。
when i use the language of union analysis you might hear spiritual abuse or something scary to you and i use this language like you know somebody is going to be very like for example like a lot of people who are not typical therapy woo-woo people are going to be very attached to ego-focused language right and they're going to really very attached to ego-focused language, right? And they're going to really want to concretely understand what's happening and they're not going to want to lose their sense of self. And so when you start to explain the hero's journey as this process of like, actually, you know, you're growing, like you're appealing to the way they think anyway to help them. And if you did that ego-focused language to somebody
当我使用荣格分析的语言时，你可能会听到精神虐待或让你害怕的东西，而我使用这种语言，比如，有些人会非常……例如，很多不是典型治疗圈的人会非常执着于以自我为中心的语言，他们会非常想具体地理解正在发生什么，并且不想失去自我感。所以当你开始解释英雄之旅作为一种过程时，比如，实际上，你正在成长，你是在以他们思考的方式来帮助他们。如果你对某人使用那种以自我为中心的语言……
like me, I would feel like you didn't get me and we're making room for my experience. Right. And a book can't do that. You know what I mean? You could maybe make, you could write 50 books and then do a personality test and then modularly have it, whatever,
像我这样的人，我会觉得你没有理解我，我们正在为我的体验留出空间。没错，而书做不到这一点。你明白我的意思吗？你也许可以写50本书，然后做一个性格测试，然后模块化地进行，无论如何……
you know, but that's not a book, right? That's, or it's an electronic book at that point. I don't know. Am I misunderstanding you or is that what you're asking? No,
你知道，但那不是书，或者说那是一个电子书。我不知道。是我误解了你，还是这就是你在问的问题？不，
I think that kind of hints at sort of what I'm speaking to. I don't know if a book would be the means of it. I think fundamentally, I believe that humans have the capability built in organismic self-regulation, right, to heal themselves. And I think that we have a lot of cultural constructs that we've designed to stop ourselves from using our organic processes. Yeah. I mean, like a ritual or activity, some kind of, some process that would be self-led. Right. And I think there's all sorts of things.
我认为这暗示了我所说的内容。我不知道书是否是实现这一目标的手段。从根本上说，我相信人类拥有内在的有机自我调节能力来治愈自己。我认为我们设计了很多文化结构来阻止我们使用自己的有机过程。是的，我的意思是，比如一种仪式或活动，某种自我引导的过程。是的，我认为有各种各样的事情。
And that's ultimately what these are designed to produce, right? They're designed to produce a means of accessing our natural way of doing that. And we do that in relationship and I can like honor that and understand the like validity of connection on a very like healing level. And I think the other part, and this is like a personal challenge is also like finding the not requiring or not being required to you like required to be educated in a way to use my own body and natural processes to be healing right like like i have i have to go
而这正是这些东西旨在产生的，它们旨在产生一种获取我们自然疗愈方式的手段。我们在关系中做到这一点，我可以尊重并理解这种连接在疗愈层面的有效性。我认为另一部分，这是一个个人挑战，就是找到不需要被要求，或者不需要受过某种教育就能使用我自己的身体和自然过程来疗愈的方法。就像我必须去……
through a process of relearning how organically my thing was if i well you could never you could one option would be to never forget you know to change the way that we raise children to realize that emotion is not, and we're not shaming the emotion, we're shaming the way that you're handling it, that you need to feel it, but you need to feel it and not let it control you, you know, and we don't do that. So much of the time, what they learn is that the feeling is bad, and then they quit feeling. Right. And I think that catches so much of it because whether I'm staring into a certain location or I'm accessing a part, I think this idea of being able to feel well, not feel healthy, but to feel as a very concrete skill. To feel whole. To feel, yeah, wholeness in all of that. I think that's, I think that, that hopefully that's sort of where the pendulum swings, right? But to feel whole is, is not to be perfect. And even if you say, I know I'm not
经历一个重新学习我原本有机状态的过程。如果你……你可以选择永远不忘记，改变我们抚养孩子的方式，意识到情绪本身不是问题，我们不是在羞辱情绪，我们是在羞辱你处理它的方式。你需要感受它，但你需要感受它而不让它控制你。我们很多时候没有这样做，他们学到的是感觉是坏的，然后他们就停止了感受。没错，我认为这抓住了很多核心，因为无论我是盯着某个位置还是在访问某个部分，我认为这种能够感受——不是感觉健康，而是作为一种具体的技能去感受——去感受完整。去感受那种整体性。我认为这就是……希望这就是钟摆摆动的地方。但感到完整并不意味着完美。即使你说，我知道我不完美，无论如何，我们不知道这一点。而且，所有的治疗都在试图解决这个问题。那么你如何在书、仪式或自我引导的过程中做到这一点呢？我不知道。我们已经为此努力了很长时间。我确实认为你可能可以训练人工智能在瞳孔运动方面做更高级的事情，我们现在正在开发一些东西。问题是，很多公司都在努力弄清楚如何将他们的产品引入心理健康领域，他们不想和像我这样的小人物交谈，因为你没有一家大公司，无论如何……尤其是他们试图把它们编程为基本上做CBT，比如那些冥想或自我引导的冥想，这很好，我的意思是也许有一个角色……
perfect, whatever, you know, we don't know that. And, and that that's, you know, all of therapy is kind of trying to come around that. So how do you, you know, in a book or a ritual or self-led process? I don't know. We've been working on it for a long time right i i do think that you could probably train an ai to do fancier things with pupil movement and and we work developer and some other things right now the problem is that a lot of those companies are struggling to figure out how to get their stuff into the mental health space and they don't want to talk to small people like me that you don't have a giant company and whatever well especially they're trying to program them to do cvt basically like the people that are met or self-led meditations and things and which is fine i mean there's maybe a role for
（接上文）对于那个，但我真的很想有人……微软说他们用于全息图的瞳孔传感器是生物识别信息。所以他们不会给我们。你知道，苹果，没人会和你谈。你已经运行了一些模型并尝试了不同的东西，但你需要很多钱来鼓励技术，以帮助引发某些反应和人类的疗愈。是的，但瞳孔的东西，我的意思是，可能存在一些我无法检测到的模式，而……
that but i i'm really wanting somebody microsoft says that the pupil sensor that they use to do the hologram is on the hololens is a biometric information. So they won't give it to us. You know, Apple, nobody will talk to you. You know, you've kind of run models and played around with, with different things, but you know, you kind of need a lot of money to, to encourage technology, to help elicit certain responses and human healing. Yeah. But I mean, the pupil stuff, I mean, and there may be patterns that i can't detect that a
一台运行大量试验的计算机可能会注意到一些比我们正在做的更有帮助的事情，或者注意到我无法察觉的微妙之处。将特定颜色的光对准视网膜的特定位置，所有这些很酷的东西。是的，很多ETT模块使用护目镜，利用瞳孔的光方向。它通常没有那么多的情绪，或者情绪是次要的。它更多是生理上的。它打破了我们体验疼痛方式的反馈回路。所以它起的作用有点像星状神经节阻滞。
computer running a lot of trials could could notice something that's more um helpful than what we're doing or notice subtlety that i can't targeted lights of certain colors to certain locations on the retina and all that kind of cool stuff yeah um a lot of the one of the ett modules with the goggles um uses light direction on the pupil. And like, it doesn't, like, usually there's not that much emotion or the emotion is secondary. It's more physical. It's like it breaks these feedback loops in the way we experience pain. So you can, you can like, it functions sort of like a stellate ganglia on block.
而且，你并没有改变医学上的东西，但人感受疼痛的方式变得不同了。关于它的情感假设也变得不同了，而且是瞬间发生的。所以如果ETT中的任何东西很快得到验证，那很可能是护目镜，因为它是最客观的东西。我的意思是，当我做的时候，我的耳朵在流血，我的耳膜破裂了，我说‘伙计们，我没有通过妈妈问题进入这个状态，这不是心身疾病’，他们说‘不，只看这里’，它起作用了。那不是疼痛，我没有服用类固醇或任何东西。我不知道它是否真的……他们会把它切回另一个，我会感到剧烈的疼痛。所以这就像……关于……我不知道。他基本上采用了数千篇关于光方向的文章，主要是季节性情感障碍的研究，
And that like, you're not changing the medical thing, but the way the person feels the pain becomes different. And the emotional assumption about it becomes different and it's instant so if anything in att gets validated soon it'll probably be the goggles because it's like the most objective thing that i mean when i did it my ear was bleeding like my eardrum had ruptured and i was like guys i didn't mom issues my way into this thing it's not psychosomatic and they were like no just look here and like it worked it wasn't a pain i didn't take the steroid or anything and like i it was like i don't know if it really and they would click it back to the other one and i would feel intense pain so it's like something about i don't know and he took you know basically thousands of articles about light direction mostly seasonal affective disorder research
然后把它们放在一起制作模型。大多数模型直接来自观察，我的意思是即使是红色洪水疗法（Red Flooding）也是这样，有人尝试了一些东西，试了试，然后他们觉得很整洁，然后他们继续尝试。EGT（情感创伤疗法）不同，你永远无法在病人的房间里注意到那些事情。他阅读了数千项关于大脑如何工作的研究，然后试图从中建立一个模型。所以它在那个方面是一个奇怪的离群值。是的，最近有一些关于通过定向光进行记忆重组的非常酷的证据。那是一件很酷的事情。是的。
and then put them together to make the model most models come directly out of observation i mean even red flooding did that somebody tried something and tried it and then they thought it was neat and then they kept trying it egt is different and that you could never notice any of those things in the room of the patient he read thousands of research studies about how the brain works and then tried to make a model from that so it's this weird outlier in that way yeah and there's some really kind of cool recent evidence about memory reconsolidation stuff by using directed light. That is a cool thing. Yeah.
好吧，很高兴你能来。我打算，等一下。所以如果有人，我可以指向你的网站，节目说明中的心理学日页面。在直播中，它们是活的。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
Well, it's been really nice having you on. I'm going to, one second. So if anyone, I can point to your website, the Psychology Day page in the show notes. In a lie, they're alive There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
（注：此块内容已合并至154中，根据要求保持索引对应）